welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
you could be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions broadcasting that other car
rental studios it's the Dave Ramsey show
work that is dumb
cash is king in the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice I'm Dave
Ramsey your host my co-host on the air
today Chris Hogan number one
best-selling author oMG personality we
are here to answer your questions about
life and about money open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jim is with us in
Tampa Florida to kick off this hour hey
Jim how are you how are you guys doing
great how can we help wonderful
well Dave the first thing that I'm going
to ask for you is to not yell at me for
making that stupid financial decision
that I'm about to tell you I'll rule the
first caller of the hour I'll never yell
at them so you're in luck they you know
I have been following your financial
principles for a while now and right now
our we're on baby step six
so we're almost done paying off our home
or actually you know probably by either
the end of this year or the beginning of
next year we'll be paying up for home so
we're really are really good on that
wonderful I am very upset because we
hustled into a timeshare you what and
you already know where this is going
what I'm sure we got well okay so we got
invited to one of the timeshare
presentations and you know I'll be
honest with you I wasn't really I was
just really ready to say no my wife was
with me and they were painting a picture
to her that I'm not trying to blame this
on my wife by the way but you know they
were painting a picture to her that I
was like all goodness you know I mean
it's kind of hard to say no here's my
point you've all the times this was last
year this was like this was last year
and we said well okay I guess we're
gonna get one so we got one and I mean
we actually already paid it in full and
you know my
question is should I still try to get
rid of it because honestly I'm just
upset at the fact that I even got it or
should we you know since seasons we
already pay for it and I know we still
have the maintenance fees and all that
kind of stuff
yeah you should I maybe try to take a
little bit of a damage to it you know
the advantage of it
you know before I decide to get rid of
it they probably don't hear that you
know hey I have a paid-for
timeshare yeah we do but I don't hear of
people buying right pay off their house
should get going buy a timeshare very
often but I know no and that's the
fairly who's really upset that's the
part I'm really upset about did you I
naturally say that you got hustled into
buying one well yes so when we got into
the present case when we got into when
we got into the presentation really nice
people by the way but you know they were
like you know they won't take no for an
answer so because and so and so because
of that it was like well okay you know
and then we're just like okay you trying
to be nice but at the same time you
don't want to get ripped off so you know
I mean with Jim Jim you're rambling
listen use this thing well they just got
no we we just got it okay yeah I mean
it's completely up to your brother
whatever you want to do I think that
what you're gonna discover is what 97%
of people discover the timeshare suck
and the the fees are gonna go up and
you're gonna feel trapped into using
that unit your all the stuff they
promised you about being able to trade
points with somebody else it's not gonna
happen
and yeah the industry is scummy scammy
and bad news and you're not gonna get
that you're gonna discover you're not
gonna get delivered well you were
promised and told by those sweet people
who are pressuring the crap out of you
which is kind of not a if you
think about it but the so I mean you
know if you want to play with it for a
year or two and discover that all this
for yourself you do whatever you want to
manage your money I mean but I I think
you're going to get in not only
increasingly disgusted with yourself for
having bought it but increasingly
disgusted with the whole process
yeah I think that's what you'll discover
but it's okay if you wait until you get
there before you pay times hearings a
team to get you out you know right right
right well initially I was hoping oh man
you know maybe I can get like a refund
especially during these times that I
know that not that's not realistic not
remotely
yeah and so I would give anything I
would give anything to you know to go
back in the past and you know not do
that but you know they don't let off the
hook once I got one so no no no I think
you're just gonna wallow in it until you
get disgusted enough to pay somebody to
get out of it but you're not only gonna
lose the paint the fee you pay time
tricks it Dean to get out of it you've
lost all the money you put into it so
you know given all of that you may want
to like Chris said you may won't play
with it for a year or two and just see
but I think I think what you're gonna
find is you're gonna get increasingly
disappointed in the organization because
they're scummy and scamming yeah and and
I would say this Dave I think we all
have to go through our stupid tax phases
we all have to and I think the learning
thing from that is all right a couple of
things I tell people you want to make
two year decisions you want to make a
decision that you look back on in two
years and you're glad that you made it
and if it sounds too good to be true my
friends than it is it truly is you know
there's um the industry that timeshare
industry is widely known for putting you
into a room and pressuring you like no
one else like no other business does and
lying and cheating and making promises
that they don't keep they've had
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
fines they've settled lawsuit after
lawsuit for fraud it's a known scummy
business most people kind of know that
Jim knew that mm-hm and then if you know
that then there's there's another part
you need to know and do you know
yourself well enough to know that you
have trouble saying no now me I mean I
do talk radio I conflict for breakfast
you don't have no problems don't have a
problem saying no no you know no Chris
I've heard that a lot I can just say no
I mean I
gotten real comfortable in my own skin
real comfort money so I'm not even gonna
be in the room to start with because I
don't wanna be in a room with people
have to take a shower after I'm in a
room with them but David's a free dinner
and so it's a free vacation for the
weekend in a crappy but little jumpy
hotel room and so just go buy you a
crappy but little dumpy hotel room
you'll come out much better off paper if
you know about yourself like I know
about myself that I don't even trouble
saying no I'm still not gonna enter it
just because I don't like being around
that kind of people they're just gross
right but then in addition to that if
you're just a person who says hey you
know my wife is that way she can say no
but she wants to be she wants to avoid
conflict let's there baby happy you know
everybody's not gonna be happy and so
she would be in there and if she knows
that about herself she she knows if she
goes in that room but she's about to get
tattoos right it's gonna come off bad
it's right and so if you know about
yourself that you have trouble saying no
that's right
for God's sake stay out of those rooms
yep because you're gonna come out of
there owning a frickin timeshare hey
Davis like my buddy every year at the
beginning of the year he would go look
at trucks yeah I told him his going he's
gonna jump the keys are gonna get up in
your pocket
go get the payment he didn't didn't hear
for him for two weeks I said what
happened he got me made a bet he goes I
got the truck I said you got that
payment dick I said stop looking dummy
go home people will read consumer
reports and study for 73 hours on which
$600 phone to buy and then they impulse
an $80,000 Porsche
the same dadgum guys a problem it's a
problem if you know this about yourself
protect yourself from yourself that's a
good rule because otherwise you get you
get to you get to have these problems
and so sorry Tim sorry you got this mess
man but you'll figure it out you'll
wonder you get to it this is the Dave
Ramsey
[Music]
step one one thousand dollars to start
your emergency fund step to pay off all
debt using the debt snowball step three
three to six months of expenses in
savings step four invest fifteen percent
of household income in Roth IRAs and
pre-tax retirement step five college
funding for children
step six pay off house early step seven
build wealth and give
let's dive in and talk about what is and
what isn't communicating well about
money and it just so happens that my
favorite show of all time is friends and
well this TV show has a lot of great
examples about money miscommunication so
let's learn from our friends on how to
avoid misunderstandings with people in
our life about money family not good
communication spending your daughter's
wedding fund on your beach house and not
telling her until months before the
wedding remember or Monica's parents did
that yes what would have been good
communication as if Monica's parents
they couldn't come up with the money to
fund the beach house and they should
have given her plenty of notice so that
she wasn't in a bind relying on that
money she needed time to save for
herself or her wedding friends not good
communication to remember when Chandler
goes all out for Ross's birthday buying
concert tickets a gift and cake and then
he Springs it on the rest of the friends
and expects them to contribute 62
dollars each well what is good
communication is that Chandler should
have sent out an email to all the
friends on the front end to see how much
they were able to contribute while
keeping in mind that Rachel Phoebe and
Joey were probably in between jobs and
shopper cash like they were the entire
season spouses not good communication
going behind your spouses back and
asking a friend for a loan like Monica
and Chandler did it without telling each
other they both asked to borrow money
from Joey and wanted him to keep the
secrets but what is good communication
would be talking about your money issues
openly with your spouse you guys money
fights is one of the leading causes of
divorce so it is crucial for you to get
on the same page with money I wish I
could have told Monica and you know that
but to avoid having a miscommunication
like this make sure you download my six
money conversations to have with your
spouse just click the link in the show
notes let's talk about preventing the
unexpected from sabotaging your budget
our emergency fund
imagine your refrigerator goes out the
average new refrigerator costs around
fifteen hundred dollars but fixing it
yourself could cost you only fifty bucks
here's what you need to do fix it that's
right you can fix your major appliances
and power equipment yourself with parts
and expert advice from my friends at
appliance parts pros over the last 20
years appliance parts pros have helped
over seven million families solve their
appliance problems while saving up to
ninety percent on their repair costs
they carry over two million appliance
parts and offer easy returns and anyone
can do the job themselves with thirty
five hundred repair and how-to videos
plus live chat on their website you can
also call their expert technicians seven
days a week or join their Facebook group
for extra tips save money and get your
parts today and appliance parts pros.com
[Music]
thank you for joining us america matt is
with us in Palm Beach I'm at welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show thank you Dave I'm
on relatively new with listen I've been
listening to about six month on JAMA
podcast cool thanks for listening I
appreciate everything you do for us
thanks have a question for you I'm
self-employed and make a very good
living my 401 K I've been contributing a
ton of money to between myself and my
wife I've got a rental property that I
owe about about $40,000 on I have a home
equity line of credit on that so I'm
paying
it'll be paid off in a year great my my
mom my mortgage is about two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars and I've got
about ten years left on that so I was
thinking of this stopping my 401k
contributions for the next couple of
years pay off my main house but then my
tax implications would be you know a ton
of money not really between well between
the my IRS my 401ks we contribute to the
last two years eighty four thousand
dollars a year you're not doing Ross
know oh I'm doing it for the test I'm 54
okay you probably ought to be doing
Roth's anyway
what net tax implication they're not
worth what you're losing on the back end
because of the roth grows tax-free and
this is none of this is growing tax-free
it's all gonna be taxed on the back end
and it sounds like you've got a couple
million in there already do you know
eight hundred thousand no was it all
okay well done good job sir you're a
millionaire I love it yeah at 54 good
job yes so um what what I would tell you
to do is you're not going to be touching
this money maybe ever you know in depth
you're not really going to go into it
and so from age 54
to age 84 that money growing tax-free
versus the tax deferral not not not not
never pay the taxes but the tax deferral
on the 84,000 that you're putting in now
I think just to forget the house for a
second just the discussion of whether
you do a Roth or a regular because
you're not going to be accessing that
money anytime soon the tax-free growth
is math mathematically going to kick the
tax deferral on the small amount does
that make any sense okay let me try it
this way
$84,000 let's just say eighty-four
thousand dollars a year going in for 20
years okay so that's a hundred and
that's one point six million that you
put in that would have grown though over
that twenty years to probably close to
ten million because usually and you got
when you've got an account that's 20
years old or older
typically 95 to 97% of what is in the
account is growth not what you have put
in when you look at your contribution to
get to the 800 versus how much of it is
growth you'll see what I'm talking about
okay yeah so the fact that that lets say
out of that 800 as an example 700 you
put you didn't put in and you got to pay
taxes on it if it was a Roth there'd be
no taxes on 7 well yeah I understand
that
I just hate coming up with an extra 20
grand and taxes yeah well do it do that
or come up with an extra 200 grand in
taxes later and that's the problem
yeah and Matt let me ask you this what's
your household income right now you're
slayin yeah and so I mean the aspect of
you attacking and paying off the house
you can do both yeah yeah you can do
well it's not that's what that's what
I've been trying to do yeah yeah yeah I
would do 15% of your income going into
retirement which is probably about what
you're doing and actually it may be
pretty close and then then just let's
knock that house out I think you're
gonna knock it out probably in about
five years not telling
and you're doing so good you can't
really mess this up all we're trying to
just maximize it that's right and so if
I were in your shoes I'm 59 what I would
do is I know you're not going to touch
the vast majority of that money you're
not going to need it you can live off
the income of some of it without ever
actually accessing what has become the
principle the original amount you put in
plus the growth and if that is sitting
there tax-free it's great for the next
generation or it's great for you if you
want to access it
you've got enough taxable already at
eight hundred if I woke up in your shoes
sit down with one of our smart mister
pros and run the math with them they'll
show you I would go a hundred percent
Roth absolutely and Dave I don't think
people understand when you utilize a
401k or 403b and it's tax deferred that
means you pay taxes on this money later
when you pull it out and so you don't
have that on the Roth side and so people
are thinking that tax deferral and we're
saying no no choose the non tax option
all the way
yeah non-tax versus tax that's right
that's right what it is is he's getting
it he's saying he's correct about this
that it when he puts in eighty four
thousand in a traditional he's saving
twenty thousand dollars on this year's
tax on this year's correct yeah that
would be about right right okay but the
growth on that is so much more and that
all being tax-free you're giving you
know you're saving twenty today but
you're gonna lose two hundred there you
go there you go
because you have no tax free and that's
a can right so even though I don't want
to give the government anything that I
don't have to that's right they got
enough right because anywhere they don't
have enough because they're so stupid
with what they do have but either way
it's the island of misfit toys up there
is the so the thing is the yeah if you
have a horizon of ten years or longer
before you're going to be accessing the
money Roth versus traditional math
almost always works hmm assuming you're
using it a good mutual fund with normal
growth rates in the market that's what
we're doing will is with us will is a
we figure out how to the Aryan telasi
how are you will good how are you it's
an honor to be talking to you you too
ma'am what's up so I just had a question
on kind of what's my next steps in kind
of my financial plan and building well
I'm 19 I'm Crowley going into my second
year of college I make around 6,000 a
year and that's before because I work on
Commission - that's before Commission I
don't I have all my school paid for I
have a Roth IRA I didn't know if I
should go into like a logo or a low-cost
index find or what what should I not
start to see the fact that you can even
ask that question makes you a rock star
at 19 years old you're amazing okay
did your parents hold you down all I was
asking beers on tap my dad came he
didn't really start getting serious
about his finances until he was around
40 he's making a lot of money when he
was younger like me but he's also
spending a lot of it too and kinda I
don't want to be put in that position
you know what are you studying sir right
now I'm a finance major and I plan to
get my MBA because I'm a year ahead
so I plan to just go on a combined
pathway so I finished my bachelor's in
two more years and then get a master's
degree of course you are okay then
you're coming to work for Ramsey
solutions right okay it's a Christmas
place no pay my place because I
understand let him have it let me go on
but you can train him up I'll be retired
all right Chris no well I love the path
you're on buddy and the fact that you
are using your parents example to be
your motivation as outstanding the fact
that you have school paid for I
absolutely love that I would point you
in the same path that we would tell
others the growth stock mutual funds are
gonna be the way to go you doing that at
age 19 buddy you are going to be an
everyday millionaire
on a faster track than many people ever
thought could be possible
the thing I would tell you is not only
do you need to play offense in building
wealth you have to play defense and what
that is is avoiding stupid around every
corner because it's out there but and
just learn to save up pay cash you can
have nice things just slow down and be
intentional yeah well before you do that
I would add one thing I want your pile
up a big pile of cash in case something
goes sideways with money scholarships
because the best investment you can make
in this discussion is called will ya and
the return on investment of you
finishing your degrees 100% debt-free
because you had a little extra cash pad
you can pull it out of that no-load
mutual fund if you want to but I want
you to get out of school that free
because dude you're going places you're
doing well way to go man this is the
Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
so you want to start investing but you
don't know how or where to turn well
anyone can do it I'm gonna show you how
[Music]
[Applause]
remember your income is your number one
wealth building tool but you have to
free it up if you're in debt before you
can start to build wealth so here's the
order I want you to attack dad free up
your income then build up an emergency
fund this is where I want you to have
three to six months of expenses sitting
there ready to protect you if you need
it and once you have that in place well
my friend you're ready to start
investing I tell people to invest
fifteen percent of your income into
retirement types of accounts so where
should you start to invest mutual funds
are the best place to start because you
don't have to have a lot of money to
begin investing in you to funds and
their diversity will protect you
remember diversification is where you're
spreading money around you've heard the
phrase you don't want all your eggs in
one basket
so how to start investing well I want to
give you three simple steps the first
thing is remember the goal is to invest
15% of your household income so what you
want to do is invest in your 401k or
403b up to the match if your employer
offers one once you get to that amount
then I want you to go to a Roth IRA this
will give you a great opportunity to
start to invest for tax-free growth now
if you're not at 15% once you're there
then go back to the 401k or 403b to do
the remaining to get to 15% so remember
the goal is to be investing 15% of your
income into retirement accounts now
remember if your company offers a Roth
401k this could be a great option for
you to do your whole 15% there remember
this is after-tax dollars
so all that money is gonna be growing
tax-free because investing is extremely
personal I always encourage people to
find an investment professional to be
able to walk alongside you and to be
able to guide you it's really important
that you invest based on your risk
tolerance but you understand the options
that help you get to your goals another
tip is to make investing easy I want you
to automate the investing so that means
the money is automatically coming out of
your paycheck every time you
paid you don't want to have to manually
write a check or go in and do it
yourself it makes it where it just
happens and you're able to focus on
working and focus on living your life
starting your investing journey can seem
like a big deal and really confusing but
it's not I want you to get the right
people alongside you to be able to guide
you but I want you to know your goals
remember I want you to stay plugged into
this information because the more we
know the more we can do if you want to
be the best you have to learn from the
best there's only one event that has it
all
thousands of entree meters 10
world-class speakers and three
action-packed dates next year summit
[Music]
Marcus Buckingham Jim Collins Craig
Groeschel Christie right Ken Coleman
John de Loney Chris Hogan and Dave
Ramsey the difference between those who
lead and those who don't
isn't talent leadership is a choice a
choice you make to go first of all a
choice to never settle for good enough a
choice to never settle a choice to never
stop learning
[Music]
but the answer is simple entre leaders
throw back their shoulders and shut we
around here were big believers in high
quality real estate agents that's why we
found the best agents in your area to
work directly with you
these folks actually care about your
financial journey they hate debt as much
as you do and won't sweet-talk you into
accepting a deal you're not comfortable
with oh yeah and there's no extra for
you to work with them you'll get access
to the profiles of trusted agents in
your area you can expect those agents to
contact you directly in less than 24
hours it doesn't matter if you're buying
or selling or both we're here to help so
if you're ready to get started
let us help make this experience simple
and rewarding with the top trusted
endorse local providers in your area go
to Dave Ramsey dot-com slash agents and
find your agent today our eye health
care costs getting you down are you
confused trying to navigate the health
insurance world do you wish you could
find an affordable biblical solution to
your health care costs based on New
Testament principles Christian health
care ministries are CHM helps christian
families churches and businesses join
together as the body of Christ to share
their major health care costs as a CHM
member you can go to any doctor or
hospital you prefer you aren't bound by
an approved health care provider list
and all treatment decisions are made
between you and
doctor no treatment approvals are ever
part of the CH and experience for tens
of thousands of Christians
CHM is a trusty affordable and biblical
health care solution and it can be the
solution for you as well visit us online
or call today to learn more about how we
can serve your family church or business
Christian health care ministries one
eight hundred seven nine one six two two
five ch ministries org
[Music]
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds comes
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
always use the promo code it's magic
the word is Ramsey you'll get the best
deal Chris our question yes we got it
here Dave this comes from Michael in
South Carolina
he says I'm 54 and my wife is 53 we have
750 1000 and a 401k plan the front hate
it when that happens
I know the funds are invested well
they're performing well got a long track
record of performance we're debt-free
except for the mortgage which will be
paid off in 2023 or 2024 my wife is a
diabetic
we'd like to retire in four to five
years but wonder how we can acquire
insurance for my wife household income
is 115,000 and we're investing 15% do we
have a chance to retire before we're
eligible to use Medicaid or Medicare I
might that happen
well here's the thing Michael you
absolutely have an opportunity to be
able to retire you guys are focused not
finished your attack in the house gonna
have it paid off in the next 3-4 years
tops
but insurance wise I'm gonna point you
to one of our insurance LPS so you can
start to walk through and understand
what's available to her even with this
pre-existing condition there are options
that are out there you need to get a pro
in your corner so you can walk through
on the insurance side on the financial
side keep chasing down knocking down
that mortgage you can be debt-free
completely and also be close to being an
everyday millionaire yeah I think you're
gonna the only barrier for retirement is
insurances and that's the way you phrase
the question I don't disagree with you
diabetes as you guys already know is a
an insurance nightmare yeah and so
you'll have to find a good independent
insurance broker and our LPS are just
that and that means they can shop among
different companies in your particular
situation the phrase insurance people
use is they're trying to make a market
if you hear that phrase in your own
track make a market means we're taking
your particular situation and finding
who wants that type of business badly
enough to not charge you through the
ears for it an example that was
um you know my home because of its value
is an unusual property to insure and
it's an unusual property to sits up on a
hill gets struck by lightning all the
time all this stuff so that when the
insurance when they get ready to insure
it not everyone wants to insure that
house that's right
not every wants to insure an expensive
car a super expensive garment and so
they have to go find insurance companies
that want that type of business and yes
it does sometimes come at a premium he
and but they're making a market that's
what you're looking for and the only way
you're going to get that is with an
insurance broker not a captive agent so
you're not going to go to State Farm and
get health insurance it's not gonna
happen
not not reasonably priced anyway right
so yeah I think that's where you put
your hustle and you just continue to add
to your 7 or 51k
ding ding you did it and you continue to
you know that the house will be paid off
before retirement and hoarding to your
numbers here and you've done a great job
and you know Chris is exactly right just
continue to work your plan push it
through and you're gonna be right where
you need to be baby
you're doing good Matthew is in Columbia
South Carolina hi Matthew welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Chris honor to speak
you guys are my longtime listener and
I'm excited to actually that's my
question okay so I'm good coming in come
definitely Charlotte and I move down
here by my see athletes on the area and
finally we have a home and we're staying
together right now
with the corner of our situation going
on I've been working from home and I
went back to working at my job site so
I'm kind of on one is about how much is
fitting my job currently on with the
home that we had that we purchased I'm
just trying to think of best options of
how to make sure I can take care of the
home and I know you speak emergency but
kind of wanna get more advice about
something that went through as far as
keeping that foundation together you
know when you're getting married
December 31st why one of the years these
weddings decided celebrate New Year's so
that's kind of one kind of it from there
yeah you don't
the house you're in together she owns it
right no I I own it we all together
you own it together both your names are
on the deed yeah well my name is gonna
be seized on the yeah we're both gonna
do yeah welcome to you know crap okay um
and you own the house from before the
relationship back in Charlotte right no
so I need to Colombian I purchased the
house and I moved to Colombia oh okay so
do you have is there two houses involved
or one new one oh I got confused I'm
sorry okay all right well I mean you you
can do whatever you want to do obviously
you're a grown man you call and ask us
what I would do I think you're in a
perilous situation legally and
relationally and spiritually and so if I
were you if you were my little brother I
put my arm around you and say Saturday
get married Saturday and celebrate New
Year's as an anniversary of your wedding
six months from now and Saturday because
you you are not what what you you're
trying to act like with your finances
that you're married and legally you're
not so really what you are is you own
home with your roommate this is a
partnership with no partnership
documents let me help you with this she
dies in a car wreck you now own and she
doesn't have a will I know that based on
the way y'all are acting she dies in a
car wreck you now own a home with her
mother and father oh well that sucks
right yeah and this is the stuff I've
gotten the deal with over the last 30
years it's the problem of setting up
house before you're married because it
sets you up and the other thing is it
sets up all kinds of relational issues
because it's hard to combine money when
you're not have not combined your thing
so all of that to say spiritually
emotionally financially everything else
legally I not real romantic but you
already you're ready cut you you already
cut your path here so Saturday I'd be
married you know unless unless it's
Friday but Chris what you want it no and
you were talking about how do you keep
your income steady what line of work are
you
when Matthew I work in operation
manufacture okay I'm actually glad cool
okay that's how you get your so yeah I
mean you you want to be a super
intentional with what you're doing as
you're working and and doing whatever
you have to do but I agree with Dave you
all going to get married getting focused
being a true team and working together
then you can be an alignment and start
to really set goals together I'd
encourage you all both to go through
financial peace once you get that
situated get plugged in to the Ramsey
Plus and if you get married in the next
30 days I'll gift it to you just give it
to you anyway it's your wedding gift and
hanging up I was trying to motivate him
I know but okay it's um like Santa well
I wasn't no one in the first part is
also now I gotta be nice or you're soft
now so that gonna completely interfered
in this business you gave him good
guidance because your ring call me about
that but here's the reality
he I'm not understanding that out of the
house with these two people who are
parents that he has no idea about and
we've seen it in the sale we've seen
this he's gonna be legal fees no you're
absolutely right it is a financial
nightmare
and so costing people out there just to
slow down people slow down and think
ahead it's like there's a study that
talks about doing things in the right
order
yep and how that is an indicator of
wealth and it doesn't apply necessarily
to Matthews situation exactly but the
buying a house before you're married
together is in the wrong order and
because it can cause you so many
troubles and that's all I'm care about
Matthew I'm just trying to help you man
on and if I got up in your grill too
quick I'm sorry but so but there they
you know there's a whole poverty study
that talks about if you will graduate
from high school before you get married
or have a baby if you'll get married
before you have a baby though they call
that the success lineage linkage and
almost all of your poverty data is when
you get those three things out of out of
order huh you start having babies before
high school grad grad or you don't
graduate high school if you will
graduate from high school
be over 20 21 years old before you get
married and wait until then to have
babies your chances of being poverty go
down like 94% whoa that's what the data
shows so it's I don't know if it's cause
and effect I'm not sure which one's
causal which one's the result but it's
there this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
my passion is a direct result of all of
the pain and all of the struggle and all
of the failures
[Music]
I wouldn't change a thing growing up in
a pretty high achieving family one of
the things that was always emphasized
was to not spend more than you make and
that you're completely in control of
your circumstances I was the heavy kid
in a pretty fit active family and my mom
wasn't really okay with that and now she
admits that she felt like my weight
problem was a reflection on her as a
parent so there was a lot of talk about
you know so many talents and gifts
imagine what you could do if you just
lost that weight I wanted to be a high
achiever in every regard not just
financially but with my health in fact
so much so that I walked away from a
full scholarship in Latin and Greek to
study nutrition as an obese teenager
because I wanted more than anything to
tackle it and I was over 300 pounds I
wasn't thinking about what it would look
like when it came time to repay that
debt and so when I got married and I
realized between my husband's flight
school and my student loans we had a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
debt and we didn't get to do with our
money what we wanted to we had to pay
that student loan debt and I just
decided I want more freedom than that
I am a big reader I'm always taking on
new books and when I picked up financial
piece it really taught me how to stay in
the moment all I had to worry about was
today we had paid off all of our debt
that was great we owned a home that was
great I had a job that I was really good
at but why is it that I can achieve all
these other things and I can have total
tunnel vision and commitment to a goal
but not be able to achieve the weight
loss that I wanted and I decided it was
time to unlearn everything I learned in
school and transform this because I have
what it takes and now is the time to do
it
[Music]
all my show all the time complaining
about how awful their timeshares are and
yet you guys have been really having
good success getting people out of their
time chairs we have we kind of helped
create this industry now there's a lot
of exit companies out there they come
and they go
time sure exit team is different I mean
we we've now have you know almost twenty
thousand people out of timeshare
contracts actual results actual results
deal our guarantee is are that if we
can't get you out of your timeshare we
give you your money back hey if you need
out timeshare exit team is the team the
only team that I trust to help you
schedule your free consultation by
calling eight four four nine nine nine
exit or timeshare exit team dot-com
[Music]
you
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five Derrick
is with us in Denver hi Derrick welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi thanks for
taking my call
both of you sure what's up I know it
seemed like somebody I apologize a
little nervous here so if I talk too
fast or whatever that my dad passed away
late December of last year and he was
taking care of my mom in the house and
mom is now in assisted living that we
got her and good position good place her
expenses or 43 to 45 hundred a month but
she gets a pension of about two thousand
we are selling and in the process of
just about to close on the house that
they lived in and dad put the house in a
trust that technically my sisters and I
own but we have all agreed that my two
sisters and I that the money is for to
take care of mom okay when all is said
and done and after the sale long-term
cap gains loan repay and some sale
expenses there's going to be about a
little over three hundred thousand
dollars left okay well how old is your
mom to my question
my mom's gonna turn 81 in October so
she's eighty right now how's her help
okay not great but better okay she's
dealing okay these are tough times for
y'all girls I'm sorry
so I'm sorry why in red energy what's
your question it's a two-part question
one is once we get the check for the
house a little over three hundred okay
do we just put it into one account and
pay all of moms expenses out of areas do
we take some of the money but it isn't
some kind of high interest earning
account and the rest in a bank account
to pay our expenses we distribute the
money between all three kids and then
say hey you got you know you have to pay
this much a month to cover mom's
expenses or that guess that's the first
part of my question since your sisters
in agreement my opinion would be and
I'll show you what Christmas is but my
opinion would be three hundred thousand
students from good mutual funds here's
the thing your burn rate is about 30k a
year from glad you told me right you're
about twenty-five hundred a month in the
hole right
that'd be 30 you said you said forty
three hundred and two thousand right
correct yes I heard 25 hundred dollars
and that's thirty thousand dollars a
year so your burn rate is thirty K you
need 30 K a year if three hundred
produced 10% it would produce enough to
support without damaging the 300 now it
won't necessarily do that every year
some years it might produce more some
years it might produce less but even if
it 10%
mm-hmm you guys are basically going to
end up with close to the 300 to
distribute to the three of you when she
passes if you can get the money to
invest it in it you see what I'm doing
if it makes eight percent it's gonna eat
some of the money if it makes twelve
percent it's gonna grow you follow me
because you need you need thirty out of
this money and if you can make the three
hundred produce thirty or more the whole
three hundred will still be sitting
there you see I'm doing the math yep and
so that's what I would do with it is I
would sit down with one of the smart
mister pros got some mutual funds and
try to get something that's fairly
stable probably some growth and some
growth and income I probably would stay
away from the normal international mix
on this and I might have a little in
aggressive but I don't know that it'd be
a fourth or a third no but sit down and
try to get together a portfolio but high
yield when you say that that usually
means CDs and that's gonna high yield
CDs 2% which means you're burning 30
grand a year and after 10 years 33
300,000 is gone yeah Derek yeah he's
dead on and I'm gonna tell you this
here's the unique thing about you all
situation that I'm proud of you that you
and your sisters are in alignment yeah
you know that that's like a rare unicorn
type situation and so rather than to
wait on that I think you take your save
suggest
put that in a gross stock mutual fund
have this awareness and understanding
you know you can have the document drawn
up that you know what happens in case
one of you whoever the executor is you
want to have the searched person that's
the secondary but the agreement is is
the primary goal of these funds is to
take care of your mother
yeah and whatever's left when she passes
we just distribute it three ways then
rather than and you can give you know
like for instance say you were managing
it or one of your sisters were managing
it with the smart mister pro each one of
you can get a statement every month and
see what what's happening with the money
you know y'all can look at it and you
can even do a little a little review
over the phone once a quarter right and
just go okay here's where we are you
know we needed seventy five hundred
dollars for this quarter three months of
twenty five hundred and the mutual fund
made ten thousand so we're we're more
than we grew a little this month or it
made it made six thousand and you know
we just eight fifteen hundred of our
money you know and you just kind of
review it so that and if you'll do that
incrementally throughout the year at
least once a quarter over six months
then later on someone doesn't look up
and go hey stout allow the money that's
exactly you know you don't get that
later yeah with y'all don't do that but
that's what Hillbillies do that's really
that's what people like me do and abuse
has happened to be married to crazy that
that's husband or spouse could cause
that riff so stay aligned take care of
your mom you guys are lots of
communication yeah communication is key
and as they said get that copy of the
statement to everybody so we all see
everybody's on the same page and we can
be an alignment you know what I would go
further I would even just write it up a
little agreement job one is take care of
mom with this money job two is how the
money invested so where it creates
enough income to hopefully take our mom
without damaging it and in job three is
to distribute the money equally and have
a community Quilly among upon mom's
passing and in the meantime have
quarterly updates and everyone sees the
account and knows what's going on and
can discuss and has input boy that'll
eliminate some drama man it just because
what happens is is that people when
people don't know what's going on
that's when they become crazy oh yeah
and I'm with Chris though congratulation
hats off to your families
beautiful people that you can
immediately kalau your sister's ago this
is not about you getting money and going
off to Vegas or going on a trip this is
about like your like everything where
you could go on a trip right now but but
you know you it's about taking her mom
which is as it should be that's what
it's supposed to be by the way it was
her freaking house you know so there you
go Wow
good job man well done that's just some
ideas you could go out a lot of
different ways but that's probably how I
would do it and that's kind of what this
place is about how Chris and I would do
it today Chris Hogan my co-host today
ramsey personality chris is another
chris is in Boston
hey Chris in Boston how are you are you
better than I deserve what's up so I
have a question about investing in my
side hustle so I work full time
essentially to do firewood on the side
mmm issuer in recently was that my log
splitter basically broke so my way of
earning money on the side died question
about do I kind of just get it going
again
and see what I can do it'll I don't want
to think it going in or do I try to
invest and move up and do one that will
help my productivity to be able to make
more money inside so how much you missed
one how much have you made splitting
wood how much money you made I can go on
the side anywhere from 8 to $1,000 a
month
$800,000 and what's a wood splitter cost
probably like $4,000 for our the one I
was looking at four or five thousand all
right and so how long as you take your
breakeven and that my only expenses are
fuel and maintenance on it
sign it be it's probably six to seven
months yep your own that catches them on
baby step number two so working on
paying off all my debt yep yep and so
you know what I'm gonna do is repair the
old one yep
Elmer's glue rubber band
duct tape
I'm gonna repair the old one if there's
any way you can't what broke on it
hydraulic lines and that Catching Fire
the hydraulic line busted and it caught
fire yeah yeah it's oil-based fluid a
day it caught fire when it hit the note
what burns the lines fill the line the
engine the air filter so there's like a
whole lot of okay I'm going to step to
then buy used 3d I think that one rental
that one's gone yeah yeah that one's
gone he's trying to justify buying new
equipment day well we're not having it
yeah well I wouldn't I wouldn't spend
that kind of money and on that kind of a
return if you could make your money back
in 30 days on a side us on baby step two
fine
but not seven months ain't happening
done it before though so it's not fun
it's like real work this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]
one of the things that makes the Dave
Ramsey show unique from other shows is
that we genuinely care about our
listeners that's why we are very
intentional about choosing our
advertisers blinds.com offers high
quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices and then their
customer service is truly unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and free
shipping right to your door
and blinds.com will help you every step
of the way
just like they've helped thousands of my
listeners with free design help by phone
and online plus they guarantee the
perfect fit go today and take advantage
of this week's special offer
[Music]
for me taking control of my finances was
really a turning point to allow me to
take control of everything in my world I
really wanted to take a common-sense
approach to these changes this time
around what I came to learn and
understand because I'm a big reader and
researcher is that the idea that all we
need to do is eat less and move more is
totally flawed all of a sudden when I
started taking kind of a common-sense
approach to what my body needed and
wanted it was so much easier than it had
ever been after I had lost about 130
pounds so many people were saying what
did you do how did you do this what was
the lightbulb moment how do you stay
motivated and I was like you know what
this is so pervasive and it's not just
the health issue it's a quality of life
issue and so I decided to launch primal
potential and use my story to help other
people create for themselves the really
common sense approach to natural fat
loss hey everybody welcome back to the
primal potential podcast
I'm your host Elizabeth bendin and I'm
so glad that you've taken time out of
your day to hang out with me and talk
about what is holding you back and I
know for so many of my clients when they
start to control their mindset they're
better able to make great food choices I
have to remind myself all the time to
not get out in front not worry about
what I'm gonna do tonight or what I'm
gonna do next week and so this is a
constant reminder for me what is my best
in this moment motivation isn't
something that just strikes you it's
actually something you choose to create
every day I have to consciously choose
my focus throughout the day all day
every day
I've graffiti'd my treadmill desk with
some of those phrases that motivate me I
have them on the wall to be relentlessly
positive
when I look at it now I am happy to know
that my passion comes from my pain and I
see it as the raw material there like
the bricks to my building but I am
defined by what I do and that is a gift
I started my first business when I was
16 years old I didn't like breakfast
foods and the protein bars that were out
there in 1990 there were many choices
and so I created one to get the protein
that I needed I created this recipe in
one night and when I did it I was doing
it just for myself I didn't plan to
start a business but it went from the
idea to create the product to making
this recipe and then realizing how
delicious it was and I wanted to share
it with others and so the next morning I
made extra and I packed him in a picnic
basket walked around to businesses and
tried to sell my product so it went from
like having an idea to an actual product
to my first sale in 24 hours and after
that I was hooked I was like I really
want to keep doing this
[Music]
[Applause]
journey has happened over 28 years there
are so many times that I wanted to quit
in the beginning in the nutrition field
can be a very daunting field to get into
when you really don't know what you're
doing I had a product that I had created
this protein snack bar and I had it
evaluated by a nutritionist and I got
the nutrition facts but so many people
in that field were questioning me about
it then there was an area like marketing
and pricing so many people would
challenge me because I didn't have
experience in those fields but rather
than stopping rather than being fearful
what I would do is I would say yes I
don't know about this I don't know that
much about marketing I don't know
anything about how to price my product
for retail can you help me what would
you do and so I would learn from their
experience that's really hard as 16 17
years old to go into a complete stranger
into a store and ask who is the person
that I need to speak to tell them about
your product tell them what the price is
and ask them what you saw my product for
me that forced me to interact with
people added a one-to-one a face-to-face
level and that's so important that's a
lot of what I believe in today
[Music]
[Applause]
being able to be Who I am from the time
I wake up to the time I go to bed that
to me is the most rewarding I don't have
to change who I am to be successful I
don't have to be a hard or bossy person
I can't imagine doing anything else when
starting a business you're gonna have
challenges it's gonna be hard it's gonna
be difficult don't stop don't give up
really believe in what you're doing
there's just something magical about
being able to guide your own path for
anyone who's thinking about starting
their own business you know if you're
that person stay true to your path and
what you believe in what you want to do
the total debt is around 640 thousand
dollars I wanting to come clean out a
credit card that he doesn't know about
I'm gonna probably pay student loans for
the rest of my life I just don't even
know where to begin you are not a big
you are the hero in your story you could
be intentional about your character you
can have money and a career everything
just started making sense I would like
I'm gonna do this let's hear a debt free
scream
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's that Dave Ramsey
show where dead is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice I'm Dave
Ramsey your host thank you for joining
us Chris Hogan is my co-host today
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author a couple times over
we're gonna be talking to you about your
life and your money the phone number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five trevor is in San
Francisco hi Trevor welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show sure what's up I had a
rollover IRA from my previous employer
few years ago that turned from 3,000 and
to a hundred thousand and I'm just
wondering because of the new probit Care
Act if what you thought about if I can
look through that okay stop a second you
turned three thousand into a hundred
thousand over what period of time about
eight years - okay
were you adding anything to that no I
wasn't adding anything it is all pure
investment individual stuff and I know
how much you hate individual stars but
yeah well you obviously did very well
congratulations amazing okay so you've
got a hundred thousand bucks in there
and you're how old
thirty-four why would you take it out I
mean I did up to a baby step forward and
I have a current flowing k plan with my
employer right now I have about eleven
thousand in there and I just look at
that re as like you know I had three
thousand before and so I'm guessing
everything else is profit so I wouldn't
mind paying I'm just gonna say contacts
and just taking the rest just to have
that cash online yeah but why
I just know just because because it was
money that it didn't it didn't grow
slowly doesn't mean we have to get done
with it
that's true but you know I've had a
reckless youth and I'm just getting to
my baby steps I have about 20 1 K and
savings but you know I'm 34 and I you
know I kind of want to settle down buy a
house and I figured this was help that's
all right Trevor I was gonna ask you
what is burning a hole in your pocket
how is that a house or is it a vehicle
you know I paid everything off I did us
to be so for a little bit all right now
but what is it you're one to buy you got
sir yes sir something's bugging you I'm
eventually like I have a girlfriend
eventually I want to get married and you
know start a family and when that time
comes I I just want to have that
available
[Music]
okay what's your household income Trevor
okay and what debt do you owe no I know
because you said that three times I just
making sure so you you're want to
eventually buy a house and you're trying
to buy that that engagement ring right
yeah okay you can do that off 110 yeah
III really would not cash it out I mean
you're giving the government a third of
your money in order for you to have
access to it that's a that's kind of
like saying that if I want to borrow
money a 33% interest
mmm so I can get so I can get access to
the money it's the same math and so I'm
not sure I think it's you're afraid the
windows gonna close you grab the
additional 10% penalty if you take it
out later let me just tell you if I were
you I would just close the window period
and let that hundred thousand turn into
a million and then get about the
business of building your life off your
110 and just forget you own that money
mm-hmm put it in good mutual funds slow
down your growth curve here slow your
roll and go from there that's what I
would ya and in his mind Dave taking it
from three and he'd grow into a hundred
he got lucky
it's like it's like a lottery money but
like you said you don't want to turn
that that fast money into dumb money and
that's that's bored that'll preach right
there so be smart my friend that's
that's the game plan I would use hey
thank you for calling in open phones
Paul is with us in Pensacola Florida hey
Paul what's up
thank you David and Chris for taking my
call I've got a question for you as far
as an inheritance what basic guidelines
would you set for your children to
follow or to receive an inheritance what
just some basic biblical guidelines I
guess not trying to be overbearing with
just some simple things well I can tell
you what we did or some of the things
that we did we view the money that we
have Sharon and I is not our money we
view it as God's money which is what
you're talking about right yes sir and
so the money and the things that we own
we don't own we're managing them for God
in order to qualify as a manager upon my
death you would also have to view the
money that way okay and so if you're not
gonna view it as a stewardship thing
you're not in the will our family
Constitution starts out in my house now
you can do whatever you want to do but
at my house it says as for me and my
house we will serve the Lord okay that
answers my question yeah and so if
somebody's going to be running around
doing all kinds of crazy but stuff in
their own personal life and and they're
not going to be you know they're gonna
say oh I get the I hit the lottery
because I had Dave Ramsey's DNA out of
the will I'm not funding some ozo on the
back of a yacht running a line of
cocaine with his money right I don't
want a grown reality show I'm trying to
grow a family right that makes sense I
was just making sure I wasn't gonna be
saying something out of line or you know
going out of bounds on something what
would that be inconsistent with what
they have heard from you as they grew up
with you as their dad no no not at all
not at all I just want their no I just
wanted to make sure that it was a
biblical thing to do not something just
me want to exercise authority over them
you know going forward I guess is the
way to say it well I mean I
you can look at it however you want but
the way I again the way I view what
scripture says is that I don't own it
I'm a manager and what kind of a manager
would hand the keys to an inept manager
right that's not it's not a faithful
steward no you haven't guidelines what
you're doing is not only protecting them
you're protecting what it is that you've
built yeah cuz I mean if they're doing
heroin all you're doing is fun and their
heroin addict know a habit right you
know you're just because when they get
money you know what crazy gets when it
gets money big crazy that's what it gets
and that's why that's where you see the
trust fund baby stuff pop out and all
that and so now nobody's perfect and
none of my grimsy kids aren't perfect no
man ain't perfect for sure but that
that's how we've got it laid out and
it's even in our trust documents that
way where if one of them wants to go off
the rails after I'm gone the other two
can remove the keys because it's the
that the point is what you're not
blessed by money when you're misbehaving
because it just it magnifies your
misbehavior hmm and al you would be
amazed at how how much control you can
put in place protective message you can
put in place for its furred young adults
talk to an estate planning attorney
you'd be surprised to see what you can
do you want to be a blessing not a curse
and when you give them something that
can control that becomes a curse and
it's not a control freak because I want
to control it it's a control freak
because I have an obligation before the
Lord as a Christian to manage money for
him and to do so adequately and that's
what I want raises I want to raise good
adults that can take that responsibility
on report yeah it's a responsibility
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys George Campbell here and I am
out of the office and downtown and
here's why when rat the Rams the office
is easy to be in a bubble and be around
people who think just like I do when it
comes to money so I thought let's get
around some normal people and see what
they think when it comes to finances we
are taking it to the street let's do it
are you in college right now and what's
stressful about it financially that I
have to pay for it now are you paying
for it in cash were you taking out
student loans no street lights no
student loans is that because a mom who
told you who told you to do with no loan
was my choice Wow so your she's really
smart you raised a smart girl I'm trying
you guys both have student loans just me
just you so what did you go to school
debt-free
my parents hilts and then I've already
paid model
one step ahead of this guy I'm gonna be
going to med school so basically the
average med school debt is over two
hundred thousand dollars by the end of
it so you got to take yourself a really
big hole just so you can put it back in
after you get out you know anyone that
is paid cash no I don't probably close
to like two hundred thousand two hundred
thousand and loans you're 24 years old
how long do you think it'll take to pay
those off probably like 10 12 years mine
is about 40,000 pounds okay convert that
for me mathematician so it's probably
not for of $50,000 okay what was your
degree in
[Music]
so I've dropped out of university twice
and then I did a degree so I've got
three different loans so I first of all
did psychology than forensic science
then I actually graduated in fine art so
now you have a fine arts degree and you
have $50,000 u.s. to pay up yeah how do
you feel about that it's pretty cool
really cool I don't love that how long
do you think it'll take you to pay off
your student loans I've been doing that
for probably almost 15 to 20 years or oh
my good even paying down your student
loans for 20 years now yeah no you want
to see it gone I wouldn't love that love
it how about you when will I pay my butt
when I die so you're like I'm gonna pay
off my student loan it'll take forever
yeah I'll just like pass it on to my
kids no excuse you pay off the loans
early you could do that I can possibly
do that's good to know our healthcare
costs getting you down are you confused
trying to navigate the health insurance
world do you wish you could find an
affordable biblical solution to your
healthcare costs
based on New Testament principles
Christian healthcare ministries or CHM
helps Christian families churches and
businesses join together as the body of
Christ to share their major health care
costs as a CHM member you can go to any
doctor or hospital you prefer you aren't
bound by an approved healthcare provider
list and all treatment decisions are
made between you and your doctors no
treatment approvals are ever part of the
CH and experience for tens of thousands
of Christians
CHM is a trustee affordable and biblical
health care solution and it can be the
solution for you as well visit us online
or call today to learn more about how we
can serve your family church or business
Christian health care ministries one
eight hundred seven nine one six two two
five CH ministries dot org
[Music]
Chris hokum my co-host today here on the
Dave Ramsey show Adam is next Adam is in
Birmingham
hi Adam welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey thanks for taking my call sure I
wanted to reach out to you we are
currently using your foundations in
person finding that resource to you with
our two children who your high school
age grin today in the investment chapter
you were discussing the imperative
diversification of up to 25 percent of
funding in a mutual fund in small mid
large cap in international investments
and so went back and pulled my current
401k stuff for myself to see where I had
my money and my options and I'm noticing
that I have the option to do small cap
and large cap
I don't have a mid cap option as defined
and I the only thing that I have in the
way of an international option is a
world equity fund so I wanted to get
your input and see should I follow that
same advice deciding 25% and what do i
do without a mid cap option you probably
have an S entry probably an index fund
sp500 fun don't you I do have that yeah
that's that's mid cap okay that's right
in the middle and it's um you know that
that's uh that's as close to me it's
going to perform very similar to mid cap
it might have a little better
diversification than a typical mid to
cap inside it but it'll perform real
close as far as the world fund the only
difference is it'll have some versus an
international I'd have some u.s. in it
and mixed in with other countries and it
because of that it will actually
outperform a typical international a
typical international fund because the
international of the four categories
that we teach people to use the
International is like behind for about
eight years so that that world fund is
that fidelity by chance
actually all I see eyes who is
three okay all right well I was looking
I was looking at a world fun the other
day that it just comes in soon so but
the yeah I'm yeah I pick up the world in
lieu of but it's slightly different and
then pick up your 500 in place of your
mid-cap although it's slightly different
but you still got good diversification
across types of funds and as that's
assuming none of those for funds
absolutely suck I look at their long
track records and see how they've done
compared to other funds in that category
and compared to some of the trend lines
in those categories and if it's all
right there then you would be just fine
doing that yeah Adam I'm curious what is
your net worth Adam I don't know how to
talk about that to be honest I just
started following Yahoo information a
couple years ago how much how much is in
your 401 K about a hundred SEC and
collected 401 k's between my wife and i
good for you well done so and you got a
really good start but that's how i would
do it
the large-cap is sometimes called a
growth and income or a blue chip the
mid-cap is a growth fund or an SP 500
falls within that category in general
the small cap is an aggressive growth or
an emerging markets fund
well the way those will sound and then
of course the international sometimes
called a foreign fund and the kissing
cousin is a world fund because it has
some u.s. in it or sometimes the world
funds sometimes our world funds called a
global fund if you just think what's it
mean it means the whole world versus
just the international or it means the
whole globe versus just the
international and that's the nuanced
difference between those and again
because it's got some US and it will
outperform the typical international so
that's cool man good that you're looking
into it teaching your kid cost you to
get your 401k to go pulled out and look
at it I think that's really neat and you
should probably I would tell your kids
you did that that hey I went to go look
and you know what I'm making sure that
I've got things in order I think that's
a great way for these young people to
not just hear about a day but to learn
it here's the other thing let's let it
be real clear he wasn't even sure
the tons of mutual funds he had written
or when he start looking at it what the
other kinds were and he had how much in
there 100 200 500 50 and didn't even
know he's doing right so what that tells
us is he was doing some things right
number one right but what we keep
telling people is well I don't know
about Dave Rams and his rates of return
he quotes and Dave reams you didn't help
you get rich Dave Ramsey's only good for
poor people well you're stupid but is
what you are because here's the thing we
know that the data tells us that 74
percent of the reason that people build
wealth is they actually invest that's
right and I get more people you get more
people to invest yeah then all these
people riding financial blogs in their
mother's basement yelling at us about
rates of return listen is he you know is
right a return had no idea he got a
hundred fifty grand out of just
bothering to invest right blindly some
whatnot I'm not picking on him he's
great I love him but that's not arguing
about my p/e ratio I'm not worried about
my expense ratio I don't know if I agree
with Dave Ramsey's analysis of the S&P
well kiss my butt guys got a hundred and
fifty thousand bucks in there and you
ain't got nothing you live in your
mother's basement
okay that's the thing man I mean
seriously is this not just ridiculous it
is what we found is that the National
Association of actuaries that which is
the National Association nerds did an
in-depth research study that says that
74% of the reason for retirement built
building your retirement success in
building your retirement is actually
investing they call it savings rate now
what do you call savings right and baby
step four fifteen percent of your income
that's the rate of savings just this is
highly correlated more than rates of
return more than expense ratios to
ending up with some dadgum money in your
pocket yes for your future bottom line
is is you know you can't get caught up
and all the silliness pins follow the
recipe follow the recipe and stay
focused that's what we found all this
big study of the national study of
millionaires studied over 10,000 of them
the number one reason they said they
invested
they used employer-sponsored retirement
plans and IRAs and you know wanna keep
some of them were so steady that they
should have changed some of their funds
yes and didn't some of them were riding
a lame horse all the way to into a
million six you know that but the thing
limped if it had been running a little
bit it have been 2.2 or 2.3 that's right
but all they did that all these idiots
that talk about things in theory don't
do is they freakin did it they did it
everybody sits around with paralysis of
the analysis mmm this is ready aim aim
aim aim aim aim shoot something put some
money in your mutual funds my god even
if you're doing it wrong
you're doing it more than the stupid but
people are doing nothing that live in
their mother's basement no you're right
and so for those of you that are out
there you may be saying I don't know
what I have guess what pull it out
go sit down with a smart Wester Pro find
out if you've got something limping if
you can make a little tweak and make it
run a little bit better watch what'll
happen yeah but here's the thing there's
no shame in your game because you're
actually in the freaking game that's
right you actually are doing something
yep which is 74 percent of the reason
for success the other 25 percent is the
fine-tuning right and understand the
investments in doing the stuff which is
what he was asking about brilliant but
listen you got the no times I talked to
a guy you got two hundred fifty thousand
dollars invested in his 401 K and some
bozo driving a used Toyota who ain't got
two nickels to rub together was trying
to tell him he didn't know what he was
doing and I'm like hey Bubba check the
fruit you know it's a dr. Phil moment
how's this working for you so don't be
don't be shamed by some intellect or
than the financial community or some
article on the internet or some bozo
writing a blog out of his mother's
basement when you got more money than
five of those people put together
because you've actually even though you
weren't doing it perfect you're actually
doing it that's right nothing dies
unless you pull the trigger baby ready
aim Chicago killing me we have tapped
into a vein mr. Ramsey is awake and
ready to roll well somebody on Twitter I
know I know Dave they're out there and
they're stupid
no it just here's what aggravates me I
don't give a crap whether they like me
or not right but they're misleading
that's right these other people yeah and
they're all sitting around joining the
paralysis of the analysis Club oh you're
right and that's they gonna analyze
everything that's the future away from a
single mom and I will get me riled up
sit around sit and look at stuff and
talk about theory and go do something
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys George Campbell here with
another minute money hack I'm here at
Cody's automotive in Franklin Tennessee
and I'm super revved up to talk about
car hacks today now I know you're
thinking what does George know about CV
joint boosts intake manifold gaskets and
clutch pack pistons well I know less
than you think that's why I have friends
like Cody
hey Cody here's how this works I'm gonna
start the clock and we're gonna take
this thing from 0 to 60 seconds in well
60 seconds let's do it here we go don't
overpay for gas you can download a
smartphone app like gas buddy to find
the cheapest gas near you also you can
use a GPS app like Waze or Google Maps
to avoid traffic jams and find the best
routes while you're at it some shops
will repair your tire for free
regardless of where you bought it
speaking of tire pressure your
recommended tire pressure is actually in
your door jamb usually it's around 32
psi I like to run mine around 34 35
you'll get a little better fuel economy
that way to clean your teeth and your
headlights with the same product good
old-fashioned toothpaste just rub some
on a damp cloth and put a little elbow
grease in it I like to use lemon pledge
it works great and it smells good too
use an app like RetailMeNot to find
great deals on oil changes near you a
lot of shops lose money on oil changes
so don't get sucked into unnecessary
repairs don't overpay for car insurance
connect with an endorsed local provider
in your area they shop the top companies
to find you the best rates and thanks to
Cody and Cody's automotive anytime
George and there's your minute money
hack life is gonna happen so you decide
if it's happening to you or if it's
gonna happen through you so my name is
Blake it's my wife Courtney and over
both thirty-five we live out here in
Denver Colorado we have two children
Hadley and Nolan they're seven and five
and it was just over five years ago that
we discovered that we needed help with
our finances
[Music]
Courtney was listening to the Dave
Ramsey show on the radio told me about
his book and his radio program after
listening to the radio program with her
we got the tour Money Makeover book and
read through that in like one night
probably over we then found out that our
church was hosting Financial Peace
University and we said that's that's
something that we need to do a month or
two into it whatever the life insurance
lesson was what struck us oh yeah we
have a family now what happens so after
the lesson and Financial Peace
University on insurance
we called Xander insurance and got
ourselves set up with life insurance
both of us
[Music]
six months after taking Financial Peace
University I was diagnosed with lymphoma
cancer I'm so thankful that I have the
life insurance prior to that because
right now I would be uninsurable during
the cancer I feel like it's harder on
the spouse then it is on the person
going through cancer as a spouse
supporting your best friend your partner
through any illness it takes a certain
level of strength I don't think you
realize the amount of strength until
you've come to the other side you kind
of inner survival mode you want to fix
it you want to help you want to take
control of it and then you have to come
to the realization it's it's out of our
control
so my last treatment for my cancer was
in December of 2014 and I'm happy to say
that now here in December of 2016 I'm
cancer-free still so it's the longest
time I've been cancer-free which is
great
I mean life insurance is just part of
life part of the budget we never thought
at 30 years old I'd have cancer
it happens so we definitely encourage
anyone out there who doesn't have it and
they have a family to go get it some
life insurance through your company
through work it's not enough I mean at
any point we've learned through him
losing his job once it's not a guarantee
the life insurance doesn't stay with you
when you lose your job you need your own
personal policy for yourself as an
individual your family to leave a legacy
to be a blessing to your family rather
than a burden shouldn't you thing happen
there's a purpose behind being in debt
we got there and God's gonna tell a
story of getting out of debt in the same
ways and tell the story of getting out
of cancer that's we just have to use our
story to help others and that was a big
revelation for us and I would say going
through cancer has brought us closer
together in our marriage it's definitely
one of those things that will draw you
closer to one another because it's all
you have is each other
and it's through those moments of going
through cancer that you realize really
what's important time that life
insurance has been a huge blessing to us
having the peace of mind of knowing that
if something happens and the kids and I
are taking care of you don't drive your
car without car insurance like you
shouldn't have a family without that
insurance to protect your spouse your
children but no matter your age
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality my
co-host on the Dave Ramsey show today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Chris James also
asked us to address the I don't know
what you call it it's a clip of our no
it's not a video clip it's a little
short written piece on a cashless
society that's going that's gone viral
on the internet that says I wrote it and
I didn't write it
oh so like it's all about conspiracy
theories and there's gonna be no cash
and the cash you know all the digital is
going to be used to track you and you
know put them put the mark of the beast
on you or whatever I don't know what the
crap it is but I mean if you read like
one paragraph of the thing you know that
I didn't write it because I'm not crazy
right there that helps here's the other
thing it interesting that we live in a
culture today that is more tech savvy
and has the ability to access
information so many different ways
through all kinds of social media and
yet people believe anything so the their
tech savvy and yet they're stupid that's
exactly right
yes I mean I saw he not has been
retweeting I did not write this in
quotes everything on the internet is
true Abe Lincoln
it'll come to you think about it but um
yeah so no I did not write the cash and
society crap that's going around and
just come on people you know think don't
retweet and Facebook is worse because I
guess there's more stupid people on
Facebook I don't know but it's like
Twitter Twitter's hate Facebook is dumb
can I get to just go on from there but
um but yeah I just think when you look
at something go I don't really think
that the president said that I don't
really think that someone said that
I'm not gonna retweet it until I
actually think about this and look at it
and check it looks like all right she
says we're cashless they remember didn't
say anything about yeah it's it's absurd
now here's the reality what businesses
love for us to go cashless absolutely
they would we've seen time and time
again studies show that when people use
plastic they spend more yeah okay we
know this 18 to 20 percent more so
businesses would love for that to happen
I've read in a few articles that some
businesses have run into not having
coins so they didn't have change so they
were encouraging people to use their
debit cards but you know I'm with you
today people will take these things and
just run it together and and crazy can
attract more crazy and the next thing
you know is you got the snowball well my
theory is as long as there's rednecks
they'll be cash the cash isn't going
anywhere because I'm always gonna have
some hundred dollar bills yeah I mean
that three $100 bills folded over in the
back of my money clip is my redneck
emergency fund and I've had one for 30
years three just well that's all that's
in the back okay in the back yeah I
don't touch that cuz you can awesome me
your wallet Wow yeah I got a money clip
I'm very real cash you have real money
in there but that's not the point I'm
not bragging about that my point is that
guys like me are always gonna have some
money to be to money me too
you know sometimes that stupid plastic
the algorithm kicks in because of
identity theft and you can't use any of
it I've had that happen not yeah could
not take to pay I tripped in Dave Ramsey
and not be able to check into a hotel
your debit cards that'll piss you off
okay so yeah you gotta have some cash
right there I mean sheesh no speed no
stupid cashless thing yes this saddle
down said we just read that out there
among your stupid friends unbelievable
retweet that we post that on Facebook
alright little wrists I feel better now
sorta not really an office all stirred
up Jewish you did James Larissa's and
Billings I was there yesterday Marisa I
was up there fly-fishing it's beautiful
country I've never been there before
how are you it's gonna be beautiful up
here yeah so right now yeah
and having some anxiety about paying my
credit card bills off I have to take
that money out of savings and paid off
and it's really hard because it's not
there anymore so I went ahead and called
chase one of my credit card companies
and I wanted to do a little negotiating
with them to settle are you behind
behind
oh I didn't know that I was asking Paul
in the out cathay if I had what would be
the better option
I don't like write down debt unless they
think they're not gonna get their money
if you hadn't paid them if you don't pay
I'm not suggesting this don't do it but
if you hadn't paid them in six months
right then they get they get in the mood
to settle because they think you're a
deadbeat
larysa how long were you on the phone
with them before you found out that
they're not budging it is ridiculous
saying you want to keep him around huh I
ride check pay those people off to get
him out of my life say chase this I need
to do that now that they would settle
with me at one point one of them told me
they would do 90 cents on the dollar
Wow
yeah I wanted to try to get that in
writing we're not gonna do that anymore
yeah and this person than working there
anymore is no longer with us
Marissa how much do you owe on this
credit card how much do you have in
savings versus how much do you have in
savings how many other credit cards do
you owe on one other and it's only about
two thousand okay you got twelve
thousand in savings so you could pay
both of these off by the time you hang
up with Dave or not hi sir great centers
waiting three more day ends of the day
get your scissors out Tom you get them
out right now let's hear some plastic
surgery right here on the air hear it
here you get them out go go over to the
drawer and get some scissors right now
do you make that don't make us come out
there to Billings so hey all joking and
kidding around the side okay when you
hang up the phone call and Pam both off
okay all right we appreciate you calling
seriously open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money Taylor is in Houston Texas
hey Taylor how are you I'm doing just
fine guys thank you so much for taking
my call sure what's up well a few months
ago my wife and I finally decided to get
really serious about paying off the debt
moving forward I sold my car she got the
keeper's because happy wife happy life
exactly that's a good car it's federal
law yeah that's right I value my own
health too you know so I drove I sold my
car body a 1980 Datsun to get by in the
meantime this is a 1980 Datsun yep he
said the 1980 Datsun 280zx is awesome
every time a train has blossoms does it
have to roll down Windows I know this
one was a very luxurious model that had
the electric okay mother
turn to do but yeah we affectionately
call it leaky because it does weak every
time it rains I love it anyway we're out
of debt we've over three to six months
of long you know emergency funds saved
up in a car there's yeah thank you thank
you so just wondering what you guys
would recommend as far as budgeting for
that new vehicle obviously not new but
new to me boys yes sir
okay is how much cash have you got well
a cyclin e1 GT for
another 35,000 and maybe almost 40 by
the end of the month okay so you've been
saving good all right so what's your
household income we make about this year
we'll probably close to 210 this year
okay well I don't have a limit then up
up to 35 our guideline our guidelines
are pay cash and your total of all your
vehicles should be no more than half
your annual income
you're not gonna violate that by buying
up to 35 and I suspect you're not
jumping from leaky to 35 no I think
you're gonna get where you want to go
within that 35 brother yeah No goodness
gracious like job saving up touchdown by
Dotson see you leaky is about to leave
y'all like sacrificing a day's maybe get
some firearms the photo shoot Leakey
send it to us here in Tennessee will
handle that bad boy will set it free
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
right now 78% of Americans are living
paycheck to paycheck that means if you
look around your own neighborhood 8 out
of 10 families on your street cannot
cover a basic emergency they might not
be able to afford their mortgage payment
they're not keeping their own money
they're sending a fourth of their
paycheck to car payments student loans
and the credit card companies in the
worst part most of these folks don't
even know why they're stressed while
they're fighting with their spouse while
there's too much month left at the end
of the money it's not okay they
shouldn't have to live that way what if
you could help them win with money you
can as a Financial Peace University
coordinator our coordinators have helped
over 5 million people learn how to pay
off debt spend and save wisely and
ultimately change their lives if you
have a heart for helping people then
you're the perfect person to become a
coordinator and you don't need a lot of
time or any special training plus
someone from my team will walk alongside
you and guide you through the entire
process join us in changing lives and
take the first step to becoming a
Financial Peace University coordinator
today
[Music]
every one I've got a question for you
do you know your net worth you see
there's a lot of confusion out there
about net worth I mean people think only
celebrities have a net worth that's not
the case everyone has one but what we
have to do is understand how to do this
well here's what you do net worth is
defined by taking what you own
- what you own and that gives you your
net worth you see understanding this is
crucial to you beginning your journey to
becoming an everyday millionaire we've
got to know the start point but we also
have to have a game plan that's why we
develop the network calculator it's six
easy questions tailored to help you to
understand where you are and to know
your network you can do this and I'm
here to help all you have to do is enter
your email address to get started one of
the things that makes the Dave Ramsey
show unique from other shows is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices and then their
customer service is truly unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and free
shipping right to your door
and blinds.com will help you every step
of the way just like they've helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help by phone and online plus
they guarantee the perfect fit
and go today and take advantage of this
week's special offer
[Music]
[Applause]
well business owners we just finished up
on trade Leadership Summit 2020 last
week and 2021 summit is almost sold out
yeah that's bizarre
it's gonna be Marcus Buckingham Palace
Gianni Craig Groeschel simon Sinek
Jim Collins Christie right Chris Hogan
dr. John Delaney Ken Coleman and me and
for some reason I do not see the dates
on this which is weird but they'll tell
you what they are I guess if you go to
the website or hit the textured summit
244 222 but it's gonna be an incredible
lineup and I there's there's just a
couple hundred tickets left that almost
sold out with the actual attendees last
week for next year so it'll be I think
it's in May again if I remember right
but anyway Marcus Buckingham Patrick
Lencioni Craig Groeschel simon Sinek jim
collins this is a lineup if you're in
business and you want to learn how to be
a better business leader you want to
grow your business grow yourself this is
the premier leadership event and
Christmas all the scores come in you've
got one of the high scores of all the
speakers oh did I yeah oh that's
fantastic yeah you never got to score
that I want any of your tests in school
but that one was really good I don't
know why you had to go there okay
we were May 16 2001 97 that's fantastic
here's the thing I don't know how each
year you pull this off I don't know how
you get people to come these are
world-class individuals people that I've
read but you know Marcus and Simon and I
mean just getting these people to come
to one location and it's just it's
remarkable and so if you're out there
and you're a business owner or you're
someone that wants to be a better leader
you you will never get a chance to see
these people in one location other than
this event and you need to come check it
out yeah it's gonna be a lot of fun too
it was this year it was crazy
red it was kovat crazy but uh
people are nuts but the anyway we it was
a the people that were here had an
incredible experience we had an
incredible experience we have to spend
time with Craig Groeschel and at the
time with the speakers for me personally
they're all just about all of them
friends yeah
Daymond John was down and I actually got
to have dinner with him him and his guys
came up the house had dinner afterwards
and yeah so he's a new friend now yep
Mike Rowe yeah Mike Rowe same thing
which is I've been friends with Mike but
I didn't spend a lot of time with him
right and it was good to just see him
he's just such a great guy every one of
these guys that were here were
absolutely stellar individuals as well
as communicators absolutely same won't
be true next year without a doubt no you
need to seriously and many leaders said
they were so grateful for the event
and the thing that I love this year more
than I'd seen before Dave was you not
only had leaders but they brought other
leadership team members with them or
other people in the business so it's
just a great opportunity for you
definitely go check it out get your
seats they are going to move quickly
just because it's unprecedented to get
this caliber of speakers in one location
I'm actually a little shocked we have
any left but entree leadership summit oh
wait this says waiting lists okay maybe
it is already on a wait list it may be
sold out okay
I'm half but reading my coffee that's
bad all right so anyway you find out
what's going on since I don't know
apparently text the word summit 244 222
summit 244 222 it may already be solo
all right Marissa is whether this
Marissa is in Palm Beach Florida hi
Marissa how are you hi Dave hi Chris
thanks for taking my call I'm good good
how can we help um so I
my biggest goal really is to purchase a
home before I turn 30 I'm on baby steps
to I make about 72 thousand a year and
my debt right now after working on baby
sub 2 is one hundred and twelve thousand
and student loans I have a TSP with the
government matched at a 5% to a total of
ten percent match Irie previously spoke
with a previous employer I had about
rolling over my old 401k so I kind of
want
opinion on how I should move forward I
will be getting married by the end of
the year and kind of just want to know
what to do with those 401k funds or just
finish paying my debt before I purchase
a home ah
Wow so you're on the cusp of doing a lot
of stuff you're looking and life's ahead
of you and you're trying to make
decisions and lay out a game plan and
Marisa I'll tell you this I want you to
make 2-year decisions young lady and
that is look out ahead make some
decisions that you're gonna look back on
in two years from now you're gonna be
grateful you made them and that first
and foremost will be cleaning up this
debt and I know you have this desire to
own a home and I have no doubt that you
will but when you do it ahead of
schedule it can end up more of a curse
than a blessing so slow down get into it
slow let's crack out this student loan
debt be intentional even with the
wedding you all have coming up save pay
cash for that thing and then gain
alignment together as you all are
working to continue paying off debt
renting somewhere for a year or two is
not a sin I looked how are you
I'm 28 okay and when are you getting
married by the end of the year on a
Florida now and says what's his
financial what's his financial condition
so we met in grad school we're both
social workers for the government on he
makes a little bit less than I do maybe
about 60,000 and he did purchase a home
where his mom lives in in Louisiana with
a conventional loan and he got hurt in
an accident and got a settlement from
that so he's pretty okay financially is
he so he's debt-free other than his
mom's home and I think maybe like thirty
thousand student loans okay so let's say
we're combined that makes you having a
hundred and ten hundred twenty thousand
dollar a year income and you've got you
said you had 110 and student loans and
he has thirty did I hear that right
correct okay unless is there does he
have a pile of money and from that
settlement still laying around I believe
he does he did that I think maybe about
thousand aside in one bank account I
mean I think he has other funds from
because unless I start hearing something
else in the math which I haven't heard
yet that there's missing maybe there's
an information I don't have I don't
think you're gonna own a home when
you're thirty okay and that's what I
wanted to call ya because you've got a
hundred and forty thousand dollars to
clean up with a hundred and ten thousand
dollar income married and twenty five
thousand in the bank account that you
can throw at it so you just can't quite
get there in in six months or a year and
that's really about all you got left
after you get married right correct so
you're gonna make it better you're gonna
make it but it's gonna be 32 or 31 okay
but when you're do it you'll have zero
debt you'll have your emergency fund in
place you do not cash out 401ks unless
it it or old 401k even unless it's to
avoid a bankruptcy or foreclosure and
because the government's gonna take all
take taxes out of it right now there's
no penalty normally there's a ten
percent penalty - but they're gonna take
taxes out of it - and so that's gonna be
like borrowing money at thirty percent
interest to get out of debt you don't
want to do that so roll your Oh 401k Stu
iras get with smart mister pros and do
that and then we're gonna give you a
wedding gift we want you to get getting
Remzi plus and go through Financial
Peace University and start using every
dollar budget and you guys start working
together as part of your pre marriage
counseling and getting ready to be
married not combining your finances
until you're married but working
together and learning and hitting these
goals and and saying okay then when as
soon as you do combine households then
you put it into high gear and knock this
stuff out and I think you're gonna have
a house and thirty-one thirty-two years
old
within three years but I don't think
you're gonna have one if you do it smart
right within by the time you're 30 no I
agree Dave and I want to clarify for
everyone out there I know the government
the cares Act has said that you can get
to your 401 K and they've gotten rid of
the 10% penalty they did not get rid of
the obligation to pay income taxes on
the money that you pull out so I don't
care about the cares Act I care about
your financial future you've got two
reasons that you would touch that money
to stave off a bankruptcy
or to prevent a foreclosure those are
the only two reasons if you just say you
don't care about the carrier I sure do I
don't care about cares don't care about
it it's not a double negative
- it's just it's just care care okay
it's a care care I don't care about care
hey queer care bears know who you are
you're Sparkle bear I know it's you are
[Music]
way too much yeah time to get this hour
over with about 45 seconds ago that puts
this hour that I rims a show in the
books
[Music]
let's talk about preventing the
unexpected from sabotaging your budget
our emergency fund
imagine your refrigerator goes out the
average new refrigerator costs around
$1,500 but fixing it yourself could cost
you only 50 bucks here's what you need
to do fix it that's right you can fix
your major appliances and power
equipment yourself with parts and expert
advice from my friends at appliance
parts pros over the last 20 years
appliance parts pros have helped over
seven million families solve their
appliance problems while saving up to
ninety percent on their repair costs
they carry over 2 million appliance
parts and offer easy returns and anyone
can do the job themselves with 3500
repair and how-to videos plus live chat
on their website you can also call their
expert technicians 7 days a week or join
their Facebook group for extra tips save
money and get your parts today and
appliance parts proz.com
[Music]
my whole philosophy was credit cards ah
I'll just work another week swipe the
card work another week swipe the card I
got this right just kept adding up
adding up and I bought this but that
borrowed for everything yeah want a new
couch go finance it want a new TV go
finance it like I just kept looking at
the numbers and I'm like we are out of
money again I was quote-unquote
successful so I was supposed to be
living the dream so I acquire more debt
and more debt and more debt and so I
think it just began to snowball from
there like I needed to reward myself for
all the good things that I've ever done
we were in our old house and my husband
came home from work and he needed gas
for his truck there was nothing in our
bank account
and our credit cards were maxed out I
just had this moment where I'm leaning
against this $25,000 truck and my
$20,000 car is sitting in the driveway
over $150,000 house and amongst all that
is our 8 month old baby sleeping in a
$400 crib and I didn't even have 20
dollars to my own name so it was in that
moment where I realized I had to do
something different we're tight but
we're doing okay in the sense of we
could cover everything and there's a
little bit left over and so I felt since
I was doing well sales and my career's
trying to take off that I've earned the
right to buy a brand new truck the way I
justified it was I only need to sell
this much each month to be able to pay
the bill
for the truck something clicked it was
like it was that turning point that made
me realize that we have to do something
different
came home and said alright honey let's
cut up the credit cards
paying off these credit cards and
charging them back up it never even
dawned on me that I was doing it so once
I got like extremely frustrated I went
ahead I cut the cards up I closed the
account it gave me a sense of relief a
big sense that really I could have been
out of debt so much earlier had I just
cut the cards up got these credit cards
everyone on the max now I cut everyone
up I cancelled him I did all that stuff
you can feel the weight off my shoulders
it's just
[Applause]
[Music]
so when you begin investing where do you
start well I tell people to start with
mutual funds
[Music]
now mutual funds allow you to invest in
all different types of companies all at
once if you have a tax advantage
retirement savings account like a
workplace 401k or Roth IRA this is the
easiest place to get started investing
in mutual funds the most important
factor to remember when dealing with
mutual funds is to invest over long
periods of time you don't want to get in
and get out you want to let your money
sit and let it grow one of the biggest
perks with mutual funds is
diversification now what this means is
is that your money is spread around to
multiple different investments you don't
have all your eggs in one basket like
you would on a single stock if you had
all your money in a single stock in that
stock tanked now you're dealing with a
really big loss as you look at mutual
funds there are typically four different
classes you've got growth and income
these are the big boring companies that
you hear about then you have growth
these are medium to large companies then
you have aggressive growth this is what
I call the wild child they fluctuate a
lot and then you have international
which is investing in companies that are
outside of the United States all four of
these mutual fund classes allow you to
diversify and allow you to understand
what your money is doing based on your
risk tolerance but you're wondering
Hogan what percentage do I put in each
we'll listen if we're going to diversify
make it 25% in each one so you would
have 25% in growth and income 25% in
growth 25% and aggressive growth and 25%
in international
if you do that you will be diversified
when you're dealing with mutual funds
you want to deal with an experienced
fund manager this is someone that knows
what's going on and they know the ropes
they're gonna be able to guide you so
you want to look for someone that has at
least five to ten years of experience in
that position now it's really important
for you to choose funds that have strong
returns you want to look at the track
record I take a look how has it been
performing over the last ten years now
I'm not saying that you need to find one
with a specific rate of return but we do
want to understand what's going on how
does it perform you want to look and
understand where's it been and where's
it going this is a good indicator for
you for what you can expect moving
forward you've probably heard the word
turnover this is how often investments
inside the fund are bought and sold
now what this boils down to is that you
want to find a fund that has a 50
percent turnover ratio or less what this
means is is that the fund managers have
confidence and how this fund is
performing so again remember we're
investing not for the short-term but for
the long haul
you want to stay steady and stay focused
and have confidence in your plan so
hopefully you know more about mutual
funds than you did when you came but I
want to share this information I want
people enlightened and understanding
what it is they're doing for themselves
and their dreams let's help people learn
more so we can do more
[Music]
the total debt is around 640 thousand
dollars I wanted to come clean out a
credit card that he doesn't know about
I'm going to probably paid to do loans
for the rest of my life I just don't
even know where to begin
welcome to the Dave Ramsey
you are not a pig you are the hero in
your story you can be intentional about
your character you can have money and a
career everything just started making
sense I would like I'm gonna eat it
let's hear a debt free scream
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the Dave Ramsey show where net is
dome cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice I'm Dave
Ramsey your host Chris Polk and Ramsey
personality is my co-host today on the
air the open phones are for you the call
is free and some say the advice is worth
what you pay for it the phone numbers
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five kayla is with us kayla
is in Washington hi Kayla how are you hi
mr. Ramsey hi mr. Hogan it's such an
honor to speak with both of you you too
what's up well I'm a stay-at-home mom
I've got two little boys and the one on
the way and I also run my own business
but I want to expand it and I really
want to grow eventually I want to run my
own company like I've got big dreams but
I'd also draft on the amount of time I
can do my business because then get him
up so I guess I have a couple I have two
questions one is how what are my next
steps to expand my business and get it
to this point right it's just really
really successful and then also I would
like to invest in a mentorship that
might help me grow but um personally
we're on baby steps too and so I didn't
know if that's okay to invest business
money back into your business if you're
on baby step 2
how much are you making on the business
last year I made about thirty three
thousand profit about like twenty nine
thousand profit okay good very good okay
so you're making a couple grand a month
after it's all said and I hope you ever
take and what would investing a portion
of the two thousand dollars a month or
twenty five hundred dollars a month
would you put back into the business
well that's the thing it's it's a
mentorship and I'm not sure how to gauge
how much I'll get out
it not what I asked I asked what you
were going to spend out of the twenty
five hundred how much would you spend Oh
500 or 700 either one less than a
thousand come on
no just one one time okay okay well out
of 29,000 what I spend a thousand
dollars on education or $700 on
education yeah once I've verified that
the education has a value by studying
and learning about it
it is long and don't look for magic
beans
there aren't any magic beans no one has
magic that when we sell leadership
training and we're dontre Leadership
Summit and those kinds of things we
don't have magic beans you know what
Jack found when he got to the top of the
Beanstalk Giants
you don't want magic babies right right
no I want to put in the work and I know
that it's gonna take time and that's
right yeah but don't don't think that
some certain mentor or some certain
entree leadership event that we teach or
something else is going to suddenly make
business easy mmm it's still gonna be
hard yeah Kayla what kind of business do
you have it's a photography business
okay and so you are the business correct
yeah I own my job and that's where I
like how David says I own it and I want
to get well but you're also growing your
family so you've got two kids you got
one on the way
right yeah so right now you're the one
that is traveling are you going doing
weddings is that your primary source yep
weddings and portraits Jason the
wedding's bringing the biggest problem
okay and see you are that you are the
bottleneck for that business as well so
you know you've got to look at it and
give yourself ample timing what can you
devote you've got this new baby that's
coming you've got to be very intentional
with it but you are right now the
product and the service and so how much
more of your time can you give and are
you charging enough for it is would be
one of the first steps I'd walk you
through if I were coaching you yeah
let's do this let's put you in Christie
Wright's business boutique Academy and
do that for
a few months and that puts Christie
right up in your face because she's all
I got her she's got her hands deep in
that stuff and do that before you pay
for this mentoring and I'll just pay for
that for you we'll give it to you and
and see if you can get things moving
with that because I think your
bottleneck right now is that you've got
a lot of different things on your plate
mm-hmm
and probably your biggest holdup is not
some magic pill for your business it's
that you just have a limited amount of
time because you're raising baby that's
right and that's okay that's wrong with
that
and you got your priorities straight if
you're putting them first but but maybe
there's some efficiencies you can gain
and let's see if you can do that for
free before you spend on the mentoring
and I'll I'll put you in her business
boutique Academy which probably cost so
much as your but you're gonna spend on
that anyway if I didn't give it to you
so and it's not even open right now you
can't get in it but I know the guy that
owns it so I can get you in so hold on
I'll have Kelly pick up and we'll get
you signed up for that we will zoom
that's it Kayla's I just spoke it that's
it we said it I said it on the air and
that makes it happen to my fix it it's
kind of like those magic beans that is
like it is like Noah's hey Noah what's
up hey guys how's it going great how can
we help Hey so I was just curious what
my conversation with my financial
advisor should sound like so I don't
come off like hey I listen to this guy
on a podcast and he told me to tell you
this well basically I have a little over
eight thousand and a Ross accounts and a
little less a little more than that in a
non retirement account then my dad had
helped me set up with a friend of his
from high school he's a financial
advisor and at the time I didn't know
what was going on and so I was just
curious a one that I was thinking about
taking out the that's about eighty six
hundred and put start paying off my
student loans and so I was wondering how
I should approach that conversation what
exactly I should say and what I should
know what questions I should be prepared
to answer right Noah how old are you I'm
23 23 years old my goodness this is
fantastic
but here's what I would do is you talk
to this financial advisor you want to
talk with them just like you were having
a conversation with anyone else
talk with them not Adam and what that
means is you're also you're putting them
through the paces they need to prove to
you that you want to hire them on your
team and so I would ask them questions I
would talk with them about your goals
and your dreams they start otally be
asking you about that but you want to
find out hey what's their level of
customer service how often do they meet
with clients
what's your access point to them if you
have questions and just begin to kind of
walk them through the process to find
out is this male or female someone
that's gonna help me reach my dreams so
no maybe I misunderstood did I
understand that you've already have the
financial advisor and you're gonna take
your money out of your Roth and you want
to know how to ask them to do that no
not the Roth the in the non non
retirement account that I have okay all
right well um okay here's the thing the
guy was the the guy that you're
currently with your dad handed you to
right right yes okay so if there may be
a bit of a challenge in that because he
may if it's a guy yow-yow
they may adopt a parental tone with you
and I would I would if I were you I
would gently not tolerate that you don't
have to be a young jerk about it but you
can just say no you work for me and I
need you to teach me things not tell me
things and if he can't do that because
of you were handed from your dad then
you may need to get a guy that you hire
other than your dad hires that can have
the heart of a teacher and walk with you
through that
so you're looking for someone and and
that'll adopt a parental tone with a
fifty year old - that's just what they
do in that business so stay away from
that
[Music]
we believe the American Dream is alive
and available not for a select few but
for everyday people like us regardless
of background of bloodline we make our
own success we choose the path to
building well it won't happen overnight
we know that investing in the future
takes sacrifice we won't go it alone
we will seek wise counsel along the way
and refuse to take advice from Brookley
we will not make excuses we will make
progress obstacles will get in our way
but we'll go over them we'll go under
them or even through them because we
have a plan and as we succeed we will
not apologize we are blessed to be a
blessing to give outrageously change our
families impact our communities and
leave a legacy we are focused and not
finished it's easy for us to all get
bogged down into finances and that can
really hinder your work performance if
you have something going on in your
personal life I just remember this
feeling of hoping I'm gonna make it till
my next payday am I gonna get the
electric bill pay our grocery money's
gone retiring and planning for the
future was nerve-wracking what's gonna
happen when there's just no money
there's nothing there so as we look at
trying to create a culture where our
employees can be successful being able
to reduce that anxiety and take control
of their lives is important and that's
where the smart dollar program really
plays a critical role for us
it's a teaching tool you're giving them
a lifelong feel FET whether it's getting
out of debt or budgeting or how to best
prepare for your future there was
something in there for everyone I was
really surprised by how quickly I was
able to start tackling my goals it makes
the work easier because I know I'm
working towards something I've paid off
over twenty thousand dollars in debt
this year I paid off all of my student
loans expect to be out of debt by this
year we don't have arguments the way we
did before
smart dog brought me and my wife
together now we can retire with dignity
the stress of carrying that financial
burden is gone we have truly changed our
family tree teaching someone how to be
financially responsible shapes your
entire life
[Music]
you
every day I talk to people who are
completely overwhelmed by their student
loan debts and they don't know what to
do but there is hope
you could refinance your student loan to
a lower rate with my friends at Splash
Financial unlike other refinancing
splash has no fees no application fees
no closing costs no early payoff
penalties or fees nothing and if you
qualify you get lower rates to help you
get out of debt faster it's that simple
here's an example let's say you're
paying on ninety one thousand dollars of
loans over eighteen years at an average
APR of 7.7% which would end up costing
you a total of a hundred and sixty nine
thousand dollars by the time you get out
but instead you refinance with Splash to
a 10-year loan at four point one seven
percent interest rate keeping your
monthly payment exactly the same and
that means you cut eight years off your
loan and that'll save you over fifty
thousand dollars sounds like a
no-brainer to me stop wasting time go to
Splash financial.com slash Ramsey check
your rate in minutes and see if you
qualify you have nothing to lose
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality my coach
today here on the Dave Ramsey show open
phones of triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five well
there's been some tough times obviously
the number 2020 is going to come to mean
sucks simultaneously it's just it's just
man it's amazing out there a lot of
people hurting you could be hurting it
could be jobless right now you could be
broke you may be struggling to put food
on the table you may be having the best
year of your life I've talked to a few
people in business that are booming in
the middle of all this mess John Maxwell
says change is inevitable growth is
optional and if you've said to yourself
I am here but I will never be in this
mess again
next time something comes at me I'm
gonna be ready I'm gonna have my
emergency fund I'm gonna be out of debt
never again hmm if you've had that
moment and you want to take the next
step to get to where you can sleep easy
and join the portion of America that's
not freaking out right now and there is
a bunch of us oddly enough we can show
you how we've launched something new and
it's huge something that will change the
trajectory of your life it's called
Ramsey Plus this is the all-access
membership that gives you our best money
products you'll earn with all nine
lessons of Financial Peace University
and several other curriculum that are in
there you budget with the world's best
budgeting app the premium features of
every dollar it syncs up with everything
it syncs with your your spouse with your
bank everything and then you track your
progress with a new baby steps app you
can do a free trial on Ramsey plus and
get all of that in the free trial the
budgeting the learning and the tracking
set yourself up so you never again have
to face something like this without
confidence so how do you do it
text if you want the free trial to
Ramsey plus text trial 233 789 text
trial 2 3 3 7 8 9 Kinney is in Odessa
Texas hi Kenny how are you good thanks
for taking my call to Bay Dave and Chris
my question for you today
my girlfriend and I bought a house two
years ago we paid cash for it
she paid three quarters of it I paid one
quarter of it and we we've drawn up
paperwork if we die if we split up you
know how the money is to be to our own
children and she's recommended that she
buy me out my part of it that way I can
put in an investment account get it
growing on top of my other 401k and
investments but I'm worried you know
because then my name wouldn't be on the
house I wouldn't be an owner I would be
a tenant so I was one to get your input
on that the data that we have from
people who build wealth don't do it the
way you're doing it okay and so the data
that we have from millionaires is they
have I I you know the north of 80% of
them have we studied 10,000 millionaires
in Chris's book everyday millionaires
north of 80 percent of them were in
lockstep complete shared goals with
their spouse we found almost none of
them being people living with someone
they weren't married to that's the
actual data points and so I'm kind of a
practical guy in that respect and so you
may want to reconsider your home model
as my point is if you were married and
you both and you had a big pile of
investments and you had a paid-for house
you wouldn't be dealing with all this
crap you're spending a lot of their
energy running sideways mm-hmm titty I
listen would go ahead or Kimmy well
she's she's wealthy I mean she's got
plenty of money for retirement she gets
alimony every month I have a great
career I make
figures I've got plenty in my 401k
plenty there like say we've just bought
this house together the only thing we
have together all our debts are paid off
and everything and that's all we have
together but like I say she was just
wanting to buy me out just then way
there's no hassle in the end if
something happens to one of our both of
us you know we travel a lot and stuff
and it's just easier you know it's in
her will that her child yes so high so
it's in a relationship either you're
just gone right yeah that's what I'm
worried about well and and it sounds
like to me she's not wanting to get
married because the alimony set up sure
we'd be the one to get married we've
both been married before and we and we
like our relationship way it is we've
been together almost five years and we
just moved in two years ago so she
brought to you the idea of buying you
out of this house I would never just
talking about investments and everything
and yeah she just brought it up she'll
say would it be easier because we're
doing our wills again and stuff like
that it would it would be calling easier
it would be much cleaner oh okay yeah
you don't think there's a problem with
my name not being on the house you know
the problem is no live there is you
don't want you to write a real problem
though that's the best relationship
issues that's not a financial issue
right and if you want to if you want to
hone some real estate you can go buy
some real estate elsewhere as rental
property right but when you don't own
the home when you don't have any
ownership rights at all to the home you
live in when the owner says leave you
get to leave there's no roads in them
that's a but that's a relationship issue
you know you know you but you just
outlined what your all's model was and
how you're approaching this I'm telling
you there's very few data points that
you delete that say that leads to
prosperity it usually doesn't as a
matter of fact so worried she wants to
buy you out of being telltale sign don't
spend that on to buy you out hashtag
we're just teasing you and we're just
teasing you Kenny sorta know I would do
it because it would clean up every word
it would clean up everything
yours me noggin I'm telling you you're
mean hit the bug here I'm conveying mean
man Canaan is North Burlington North
Carolina I can and how are you good how
are you Dave are you Chris better than
we deserve for sure
what's up yeah this got a quick question
for you guys so last year my wife worked
at a credit union for about ten months
while she was finishing up nursing
school and they started taking some of
her income and putting it into it their
401k well about the time that they left
there was only about 450 dollars in her
401k and they said that they wouldn't
allow that the standard 401 K so they
rolled it over to just one of the thanks
investments and then charged 50 dollars
for the direct rollover these people are
sharks yes
nope you're all over here $56 account
and charge you $50 to do it it'd be
better for me to just withdraw it on
another twelve percent tax bracket would
it be better permitted with all four
dollars and pays 48 dollars in taxes or
pay another $50 rollover to get it and
some money it doesn't matter if you just
set fire to it it won't change your life
so I'm certainly not leaving it with
those carrot No so either move it and I
don't know that that unless they charge
you another rollover fee to get it out
of there but I you know it's 450 bucks
man it doesn't matter it's not gonna
it's gonna make your break your life
either way so stay away from these
people moving forward yeah hey so what
do you learn from this banks charge fees
be watching for them yep be watching for
them Aaron is with us Aaron is in women
limit leave it come on get the right
button here Dave there we go Aaron's in
Nashville hi Aaron how are you wait a
minute now you're not even there I'm oh
god I screwed it up completely I think
got hung up on him then he's gone
yeah well he'll call back maybe call
Berger sorry Aaron tell me I'm the mean
one why you know you're the mean when
I'm the clutch yeah hit the wrong button
I hit the hang-up button and you think I
know how to work this crap by now after
30 years but I don't all right
anyway Chris Hogan is here to help me
get through this other half-hour on the
Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
everywhere returned we hear negative
financial news that everyday people
can't succeed that the American Dream is
dead but is this really true we went on
a hunt to see what a millionaire really
looks like well welcome everyone I'm
gonna ask you a series of questions and
if you can answer yes to any of the
questions come across the line we hear
that wealth is gained through family
money or just pure luck
how many of you inherited a large sum of
money
[Music]
people believe that only those with an
advantage in life can truly be
successful if you've had an individual
income of 250,000 or more please come
forward
maybe you think that if you could just
get that raise or that promotion it
would all work out but what if that big
break never comes
can people with everyday jobs like
teachers and firefighters build real
wealth what about the self-employed or
the single parents that are doing the
best they can to provide for their kids
or those who grew up and lower to
middle-income households do they have
the same chance at success or can
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth I've got one final question for
you how many of you are millionaires
[Applause]
[Music]
all of us are tempted to believe that
millionaires had a head start or some
kind of advantage in life but those are
just myths there are everyday people and
they're hiding in plain sight
and I want you to understand that anyone
can become a millionaire no matter what
you come from and we want to show you
how we've conducted the largest study of
millionaires ever and I wrote a book
about how they achieved it and the
results will shock you what were their
habits their behaviors what did they do
that most people don't these insights
will inspire and challenge you it
doesn't matter where you come from you
too can become an everyday millionaire
this is your invitation
[Music]
it's the truth you guys one day you will
pass away and one day you need to take
care of your family your loved ones
we're gonna talk about how you can do
that today I see you right after this
[Music]
something real I'm 35 years old am i
excited to talk about the day that I
will leave this earth no I'm not excited
about it but the truth that effect is it
is coming but here's one thing I do
believe in that we have to properly
improperly plan to protect our family to
protect our loved ones I really want you
to look into life insurance life
insurance is important the majority
Millennials do not have life insurance
why I'm young I have time I don't need
it yes you do need it I'm young but I
have it I want to make sure that my
family can bury me properly and that my
mom and my dad and my siblings and my
loved ones they can actually mourn a
little bit be like alright it's peaceful
here's what I recommend when it comes to
life insurance I want you to get term
life that's gonna be 10 to 12 times your
income so for an example if you're
making a thousand dollars a year that
means you're gonna get anywhere from ten
to twelve thousand dollars for a life
insurance policy if you're making a
hundred thousand dollars a year this
means you should have anywhere from a
million to 1.2 million dollars in a life
insurance policy if you are young and
single leave that to your parents then
to your siblings if you are married you
leave that to your spouse if you're
married with children you leave the
majority of it to your spouse and a
little bit to your children and then if
you want to go down to your family as
far as a mom and parents you can let me
just be real with you is this a popular
subject to talk about it's not but you
know what the decision that I made today
now impacts my family so going ahead and
check out the covers checkup link below
let me know if you do it comment below
get life insurance if you're a
millennial I want you to make sure that
you are really doing your
responsibilities to take care of your
family yo I love y'all peace out
let's talk about preventing the
unexpected from sabotaging your budget
our emergency fund
imagine your refrigerator goes out the
average new refrigerator costs around
$1,500
but fixing it yourself could cost you
only 50 bucks here's what you need to do
fix it that's right you can fix your
major appliances and power equipment
yourself with parts and expert advice
from my friends at appliance parts pros
over the last 20 years appliance parts
pros have helped over 7 million families
solve their appliance problems while
saving up to 90 percent on their repair
costs they carry over 2 million
appliance parts and offer easy returns
and anyone can do the job themselves
with 3500 repair and how-to videos plus
live chat on their website you can also
call their expert technicians seven days
a week or join their Facebook group for
extra tips save money and get your parts
today at appliance parts pros calm
[Music]
Bram's personality chris hogan is my
co-host today here on the Dave Ramsey
show open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five Camila is in
Las Vegas hi Camilla how are you hi Dave
and Chris it's a pleasure to speak to
you guys today you too how can we help
okay well my husband and I are going
through a divorce and we own a small
business together and I'm wondering what
formula to use to split up that small
business I'm sure how long you been
married
thank you we've been married ten years
what happened he what he just walked out
of the marriage
so who's been running the business tell
me how that works he runs the business
day-to-day I've worked in the business
throughout the years but he's taken over
all those responsibilities in the last
six months okay so what do you plan to
do with your life um I'm not quite sure
yet I'm working on that
I'll go did he walk out um a couple um
let's see probably make three months ago
how many kids you got three kids what
age um eight years old four years old
and a year and a half
so I assume over this three months he's
begun paying child support during the
separation correct um we've had our
accounts together
still we've always been working together
at it we have one account and just and
he's living with his parents so it
doesn't have any extra expenses so
you're just using the money with the
combined accounts to take care of the
family yes
do you all own anything else any money
we own our cars and and we that's it
yeah that's the only thing that we
haven't any money anymore there's no
retirement yeah we have
we both have retirement accounts like
$15,000 each and we are home we have a
little bit of equity and probably like
$100,000 worth of equity and what's the
home worth it's worth about $300,000 so
you owe 200 were you a stay-at-home mom
or did you work I was working in our
business okay but yeah but not not a
regular set time yeah it's changed and
it changed over the years that we had
the business and we've had it for five
years
what is your attorney saying I don't
know I haven't gotten their advice about
it yet
okay let me help you there's three
months after your husband walks out
lives with his parents is too late to
get an attorney so yeah no I have one I
just we've been trying to mediate mostly
and not use attorney okay that's fine
there's nothing wrong with mediating but
you need an attorney to close and put a
lid on this and so you're not getting
any legal advice at all I am I guess I
just don't know what the right questions
to ask are well
legal advisors the legal advice says
that you're going to get a pile of child
support from him for three little kids
and the legal advice then should say
that you're getting half of everything
else at least yeah okay yeah so here are
what's what is the net profit on the
business in a year net profit taxable
income what did you all pay taxes on
last year last year it was $40,000 okay
well the business is probably worth
between if that's an exact figure it's
worth somewhere around four times that's
around 160 okay and so if you sold the
house and you took his retirement
account and you got the equity out of
the house and he got the business that's
probably not a bad trade okay so you had
thirty thousand in retirement at that
point you got a hundred thousand and you
get your car you get the most expensive
car of the two you're getting pretty
close to half of the assets at that
point okay and he has the business free
and clear of you and then he can run it
and pay child support and maybe alimony
depending on what you come up with yeah
okay I also wanted to mention that in
the beginning of 2019 we bought out a
partner that we had for 36 that I had 30
percent we bought them out for $90,000
you overpaid yeah that's what I'm
guessing so and you paid cash for that
no we took out a second loan on our home
to do that has that been paid off and
we've been paying it down but no it's
not paid off yet that's part of the
equity in the home you're getting in my
scenario so that is an interesting part
of the equation you know so what I'm
trying to do is to get you half of the
assets and him end up with the business
because you don't want to remain in the
business from again with a guy you're
divorced from right you know you don't
want to trust him to give you
accurate numbers on the P&L no yeah he's
already locked me out of all the
accounts oh yeah and and and here's the
deal he doesn't want you to get an
attorney just because he's trying to get
it done as cheap as possible and he's
trying to probably I think he probably
need legal counsel you you do Camela
that's the only way you're gonna get a
clarity and it's gonna be an equal and
it's gonna be something that you get
done in the best interest of their
children I trying to pick a fight I'm
just trying to keep you from getting
bullied right yeah it's time to make the
phone call young lady
yeah I agree it is and you walk them
through what you've been through and
that you'll they'll hear in your voice I
hear it the fear and the nerves but
you're gonna be okay and here's the last
part of the equation and it's just gonna
add to your pain not take away from it
on the short-term but on the long-term
it's gonna help you unless you're going
to land a very very serious career very
quickly like $80,000 income or above
you're not going to be able to stay in
this house yeah I'm planning to sell it
and those cheaply okay good and then
you've got to get your career started
and start putting tools in your belt
with that money that you get house I
think you get the house equity and the
nicest car and all the retirement
accounts and then maybe some more okay
and then he gets the business that's
because the business is probably worth
about four times forty so somewhere but
maybe five times so somewhere between
160 and 200 is his question and if you
can get everything else to add up to
close to that you're getting pretty
close or have him you know give you 50
grand he goes to the bank gets it I
don't care what he does at this point
he's walking off for my wife and three
kids like I ain't much use for it so I'm
man what a mess it is yeah I think the
best plane can buy the whole call though
Chris is what you said that she needs an
attorney she does and not everybody the
ends of marriage is a horrible guy no
not me guy passion so you stupid people
to send me that stuff I don't guy bash
every you know we don't know the whole
situation but all we're hearing all
we've got is what she told us the facts
yes the details so but I
yeah you're entitled to I think more
than it is being hinted that you're
going to get that's my opinion and
listening to it and sometimes that just
requires standing up and that's what
Chris is saying so get some legal
counsel I would get the house sold take
all of that money I'll take one or two
cars and take all the retirement and
maybe somehow the business if there's
unless there's some other money
somewhere else but I tell you what I
also love the fact that you're just
being straight up with her let her know
that that house can't stay so she can
emotionally he's already done it yes she
was aware that's a good thing a lot of
people try to hold on to a house you
can't afford out there i horse keep the
kids stable on the how all this stuff
and it continues the nightmare yeah it
really it Orton's it this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
but first let's talk about one of the
biggest ways to put money back in your
pocket look I get it
cars are a status symbol in our world
today people look at your car and just
assume they know everything about you
and you might see someone drive like
this really nice car and you just assume
that they have a lot of money but the
truth is most people do not own their
cars no they are paying the bank not
themselves and in my personal humble
wise opinion a car loan is honestly
probably the dumbest type of debt that
you can get into because look just look
at the math you're taking out a loan and
paying interest on something that is
going down in value so mathematically
speaking this is not smart so let's just
look at the reality of car payments
today okay it's a lot of numbers but
stay with me the average car payment is
545 dollars over 69 months so almost six
years a ping 545 dollars every single
month
I just keep think about how many pairs
of shoes I could buy with that much
money you guys say and then on top of
that your car loses 25% of its value the
instant you drive it off the lot if you
buy a brand new car now here's where the
math really gets you the average total
car loan is thirty one thousand seven
hundred and twenty-two dollars now by
the time you finally pay off that car
six years later you've actually paid
thirty seven thousand six hundred and
five dollars in car payments now on
something that's worth $10,000 yes
because your car goes down and follow
you over those six years so when you
look at it it's just it's crazy now on
the other hand what would it look like
if you paid cash for a car and you
invested that car payment instead of
paying it to the bank so if you invested
five hundred and forty five dollars a
month with the average annual rate of
return of ten to twelve percent in about
thirty years you would have one point
four million dollars
yeah I hope you like the car I mean I
heard that was like oh my gosh that is
insane over a million dollars that is
what your car payments are costing you
so do not your future with a car
payment you can pay for a car in cash
people do it every single day people
call my show all the time complaining
about how awful their timeshares are and
yet you guys have been really having
good success getting people out of their
timeshares we have we kind of helped
create this industry now there's a lot
of exit companies out there they come
and they go time sure action team is
different I mean we we've now have you
know almost twenty thousand people out
of timeshare contracts actual results
actual result big deal our guarantee is
that if we can't get you out of your
timeshare we give you your money back
hey if you need out timeshare exit team
is the team the only team that I trust
to help you schedule your free
consultation by calling eight four four
nine nine nine exit or timeshare exit
team dot-com
[Music]
our scripture of the day Romans 15 5 may
the God who gives endurance and
encouragement give you the same attitude
of mind toward each other that Christ
Jesus a
their friend lou holtz said says ability
is what you're capable of doing
motivation determines what you do
attitude determines how well you do it
that guy is a dynamo yes see if he came
and spoke last week at our entree
Leadership Summit he's 83 years old two
weeks ago his wife passed away and was
buried and he came from Orlando up here
to do the event up to Nashville an
absolute gentleman yes he's an absolute
dynamo and a world-class communicating
the energy that came off that stage man
I want to be him when I grow up
yeah or two you could just see and feel
just the passion and the this man is
absolutely the epitome of attitude and
character and just caring about what it
is that he does and growing all of these
young men these many years in the sport
of football he is he's a good man he's a
very good man it was really fun
you know world-class communicator but in
the midst of all kinds of peril yeah I
mean open on troubles he still stands up
there and just just calm whole month yes
yeah absolutely amazing all right Apple
is with us in Long Island hi how are you
okay Dave I just want to let you know
that I did call you eight years ago and
I paid off my mortgage right ago I did
because I had a little bit of an
inheritance and I paid it but I I'm
still in my house I'm divorced and I had
seven hundred thousand dollars in
retirement funds and I don't I'm doing a
lot of reading lately and it doesn't
seem like that's enough and also I
looked at the rules like you take the
age 100 and you subtract your age which
minus 70 and you shouldn't have more
than 30% I get some stocks in your
portfolio and mine that's an idiot okay
all right well I
I was an idiot for a long time I during
the boom years the last three years I
had all my retirement funds and CDs and
I changed it to Vanguard in February and
now he had it there for a couple of
weeks and then the Cova thing happened
and I lost a tremendous amount but I
have it all back now
well it's back so you didn't tell you
know you wrote it out I did smart good
job Michael good job yes well I didn't
sleep for a couple of weeks but I did
why do that but now I'm wondering I have
pre-election jitters I don't want to get
too political but if President Trump
doesn't win I'm afraid that the market
may not do so well and I'm afraid of the
same thing happening another died and
I'm wondering if I should cash out now
since I have everything that I have or
what I should do you know I heard I've
been on the air almost 30 years and I've
heard that every election you know this
one seems a little different I know it
does my different the players are
different yeah I was during the Obama
year so I was I was an unhappy I was a
had a lot of trepidation out that way as
or things closing on Long Island and I
just thought I don't know and I'm very
concerned yeah well whether you agree
with someone's politics or not if you
look at the historic ride of the stock
market as an investment it really other
than occasional blips here or there has
not necessarily followed a party okay it
actually boomed under Bill Clinton it
boomed under Ronald Reagan it dove under
Ginnie Jimmy Carter so I mean there they
can they can do things to screw it up
but they really have to work at it to
screw it up because this economy is just
more robust than
who's in the White House and now can
they do things to make the business
climate more friendly to make money in
business which helps the stock market go
up yes they can do all of that but it's
not a guarantee what happens in your
house is and you know the bottom line is
people are going to still go to Home
Depot regardless of who's in the White
House they're still going to buy an
iPhone regardless is in the White House
they're still going to do whatever and
those companies make that money so I
don't disagree with the concern about
our nation and the lack of character
among anyone that is running anywhere
ever but the but I don't disagree with
you on that but but I wouldn't freak out
about that now if you want to be a
little bit more conservative in your
portfolio that's fine but no I would not
have thirty percent and mutual fund
you're healthy and vital at 70 there's a
strong chance statistically you're gonna
live to 90 and if you my father just he
died and he was 92 there we go all right
so the thing is you got you got 20-some
odd years in 30 years that you're gonna
ride the market and so this idea and
even after that the you know your heirs
will and so it's I I think you're fine
and when I am your age I will be 100%
invested in the market in terms of in
terms of mutual fund purchases I won't
be sitting in cash and bonds and this
other crap that these people put out
well daven that's why it's really
important to have that that smart Wester
Pro in your corner that you can have a
conversation with talk about these
things in a rational way or an
irrational way either way your get an
opportunity to get some wisdom injected
into whatever your politics might be you
know it's a good point cuz yes some are
at the grand like she's got you're
sitting down with your smart mr. Pro and
they can walk you through the trend line
of exactly what I'm talking about
mm-hmm where you say okay you remember
when you thought Bill Clinton was going
to bring into the universe remember when
you thought Ronald Reagan was going to
bring in whichever your politics you can
stand you can look at it and the trend
lines just don't follow your fears no
it really doesn't and your you're
investing will follow your intention and
so you want to have a plan but it's good
to have the conversation and to be able
to see it but you know for goodness
sakes do not I checked out of the market
it's just it's unnecessary and it's
costly financially to be honest well the
news cable news you just can I use that
as your investment at all your
investment advisor needs to be someone
to show your actual historic data and
then you say okay yeah I think this is
crazier than it was back then okay so I
had a crazy factor to it but it's still
not going to say the world is gonna come
to any end that's right markets gonna
dive you know as it's no open phones I
can't even think about what to say is
just yeah it's it's horrible what could
happen into in society yes but but the
truth has been the over the 30 years
I've done this and even when you look
back further than than that and the
trend lines the truth has been that what
happens in your house is 90 something
percent of the equation not what happens
in the white house that's right and so
quit trying to elect someone to fix your
life or being afraid that someone's
going to destroy your life that's going
to be affected they just don't have the
power unless you give it to them that's
right that's exactly right we do we we
live in a democratic society with checks
and balances and ultimately you need a
budgeting plan in your own you need an
emergency savings plan in your own you
need a plan for your future and you need
a spending plan and those things are
very realistic and those are things that
we can control yeah but I'm not gonna
stop buying real estate though I'm not
gonna stop buying good gross stock
mutual funds over a long period of time
in my 401k
I'll turn 60 here shortly and so I'm
gonna continue to do that I'm not gonna
stop doing the things that got me here
that's right because of who goes into
the white house that's right I agree it
may or may not do better or may or may
not do worse but it's not going to
substantially change staying sidelining
yourself and going into CDs cost you a
lot more than those guys being elected
to cost you yes that's what we're going
to
so interesting stuff Chris Hogan thanks
for hanging out good job today
thank you my friend thank you it's
always a pleasure great great job
co-hosting today here on the Dave Ramsey
show that puts this hour of the Dave
Ramsey show in the books our thanks to
James childs our producer Kelly Daniel
our associate producer and phone
screener
I'm your host Dave Ramsey we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
when we first decided to sell our home
the first decision we probably wanted to
make was to find a real estate agent my
dad suggested a Dave Ramsey LP we went
online to the Dave Ramsey website and we
put in our information and it was like
instead one of our biggest concerns was
getting someone who understood the
market and understood how to sell the
house but also understood how to get us
into the house I wanted to be and that's
what we got with Troy we knew that he
was already vetted that he was someone
that was trustworthy by the EOP program
standards and that helped alleviate all
that concern and fear
I think the first weekend we had four
offers
[Music]
the ELP program is a way for people that
are either looking to buy or sell a
house and be paired with the person that
is closely aligned with their financial
values and one of the biggest financial
decisions that people make in their
lives
[Music]